not quite getting the results you want
from chat GPT wondering how you can use
AI language models to your advantage
then this course is for you if you have
spent any amount of time with AI
language models like chat GPT and Google
bard you may have noticed the results
can sometimes be a little frustrating
effective prompt engineering is the
secret sauce for getting the most out of
AI in this course treasure por will
teach you the Art and Science of
effective prompt engineering to get the
most out of AI language models and help
you become a better web developer
treasure is a software engineer and
she's a technical content developer at
scrimba hi free code Camp Learners
welcome to my course on prompt
engineering for web developers prompt
engineering is the Art and Science of
communicating with AI to yield better
more precise more robust results AI
interfaces like chat GPT and Google bar
do a little bit of everything from
writing silly poems to to summarizing
large text to generating code Snippets
this course is designed specifically
with web developers in mind so it's
packed with ideas strategies and
practice challenges that are going to
help you get the most out of AI language
models as a coder you're going to learn
how to use prompt engineering to
transform an AI language model into a
par programming partner a personal
coding tutor and even a career in
interview coach with the help of AI
you're going to be coding better and
faster than you ever have before so I
hope you're excited to get the most out
of this course you should have some
experience writing JavaScript and react
but whether you're a senior Dev or just
starting out there's something in this
course for you so thank you so much for
joining me and let's get
[Music]
started hello prompt Engineers welcome
to my course on prompt engineering
created specifically for web developers
we are entering a future in which web
development is so much more than writing
code it's about leveraging artificial
intelligence to supercharge your coding
skills to build smarter and faster and
this course is all about showing you how
firstly though hello my name is treasure
I've been a friend and developer since
2015 and a teacher and instructor for
even longer than that I switched careers
after going through a boot camp and I
love traveling karaoke and singing in a
choir I've done hundreds of hours of
research coding and experimentation with
AI language models and I'm really
excited to share what I've learned with
you there's been so much Buzz about AI
recently that you've probably heard a
lot about language models like chat GPT
or Google bard by now so I'm going to
give you a very Lightning Fast
definition language models are
artificial intelligence tools that allow
you to have humanlike conversations with
a computer language models like chat GPT
can help humans do pretty much anything
involving words whether it's ad copy
poetry or helping you brainstorm a list
of names for your new cat I've split
this course into three sections the
first section covers many tips tricks
and strategies to design and refine your
AI prompts to get the most out of
interacting with AI language models the
second section is a collection of prompt
ideas and examples exploring how you as
a developer can use AI language models
to generate document and debug your code
as well as use it as an Interactive
Learning tool you'll learn some
practices to help you use AI as a PA
programming partner a rubber ducky if
you will that not only listens to you
but helps you find Solutions and the
last section is all about using AI
language models to enhance your job
search I'll show you examples of how to
use AI for everything from finding
places to apply to learning and
practicing algorithmic coding challenges
to generating and practicing behavioral
interview questions for this course
we'll mostly be using open ai's public
interface commonly known as chat GPT
with a little bit of Google barge
sprinkled in I highly recommend that you
follow along and experiment with your
own prompts and you can click on the
logos to visit the public interfaces for
these AI language models and sign up for
an openingi account if you need to
before we go into any further I want to
quickly address a common question that
pops up when people start learning about
AI will AI replace developers or make it
harder for me to break into the tech
industry tragically I'm not a time
traveler or a psychic or even an expert
on industry Trends so I can't
definitively answer this question but
what I can say is that being a developer
is so much more than being able to spit
out code it's about understanding the
user and how to create products and
services that are intuitive Pleasant to
use fast and that solve real world
problems to make people's lives easier
it's about empathy and creative problem
solving and Innovation working as part
of a team and the list goes on at this
moment in time we still need humans to
do that and right now language models
are really only good at one thing and
that is guessing what word should come
next giving a sequence of words at the
end of the day language models are
simply trying to predict which words
should come next AI language models are
also only as good as the data they're
trained on they are prone to making
things up and they become less effective
as the complexity of your problems or
your code bases goes up so the short
answer is no in my opinion AI is unfit
to replace developers anytime soon
language models are best used as tools
to streamline the most tedious rote
tasks of a developer bringing us up to
focus on bigger more complex more
interesting problems now that that's
settled and you know what you're in for
let's talk a bit about prequisites it's
important to note that while you don't
have to be an expert you should have
some experience with JavaScript and
reactive be successful in this course as
long as you've done some basic coding
this course should give you a wealth of
ideas for how to harness the power of AI
in your webd Dev workflow so let's go
let's do
it the first step to getting the most
out of AI is learning effective prompt
engineering so let's talk about what
prompt engineering actually is this is a
relatively new term that you may have
heard out in the wild in all of the talk
about AI recently and at first glance
you might assume like I did that prompt
engineering is a way to say software
engineering via prompting a language
model but it's actually a much more
generalized term prompt engineering
means crafting prompts to effectively
guide a language model's responses
here's another definition designing and
refining inputs to obtain your desired
output I like to think of prompt
engineering as The Art of Getting AI to
do what you want whether you want AI to
write an essay or make art or produce
code for you how you engineer prompts
depends largely on what you want the
language model to produce in our case
we're going to talk about prompt
engineering specifically for front-end
development and our desired output is
code or information about code when it
comes to AI assisted coding a
well-engineered prompt ensures gpt's
output is tailored to your specific
needs and it's going to mean hours of
development time saved from repetitive
boilerplate code debugging and a lot
more for the next part of the course
we're going to discuss prompt
engineering specifically for frontend
development and here's a sneak peek of
the basic Strat strategies for Effective
prompt engineering we need to be
specific use technical terms provide
context give examples and perhaps most
importantly iterate so we're going to go
through each one of these strategies
look at a ton of examples and you're
going to learn a wealth of great tips
and tricks it's going to be great so
let's dive into it I'll meet you in the
next
scrim let's talk about the basics of
writing effective prompts it's very much
a worthy Endeavor to take the time to
craft a great prompt when working with
language models like GPT a great prompt
can mean the difference between Broad
and largely unhelpful responses from the
AI to finally tuned outputs that save
you potentially hours of time I highly
encourage you to follow along with me
and try all of these prompt examples out
yourself and you can click on this image
to go to gpt's public interface keep in
mind as we start looking at examples
that there's a certain Randomness to how
chat GPT outputs information so even if
you enter in the exact same prompt your
output is probably going to be a little
different from what chat GPT has given
me how it responds depends on a variety
of factors like I said Randomness and it
can also vary depending on your prompt
history and which model you're using so
just keep that in mind the responses
will be similar most likely but probably
not exactly the same let's talk about
strategies for Effective prompt
engineering the first three are be
specific use technical terms and provide
context here's an example of a not so
great prompt how do I Center something a
slightly better example of this prompt
would be how do I Center an element on a
web page and an even better example is
what's the best way to Center div
element horizontally and vertically
using CSS let's see what happens when we
enter this into GPT when I use the broad
prompt how do I Center something GPT
says well I need more context what are
you trying to Center and how are you
trying to center it are you talking
about physical space or a digital
environment are you centering a word
processor on a website graphic design
software more information please so then
I prompt again with something a little
bit more specific and a little more
technical I'm saying I want to Center an
element on a web page now GPT responds
with well you can use cascading
stylesheets there are several ways to
achieve this but it recommends that we
use flexbox or css grid notice here the
assumptions that GPT is making based on
our prompt it's perhaps assuming that we
may not know what cascading stylesheets
are it then provides us with some code
for the HTML and CSS for flexbox and for
grid let's see what happens if I refine
The Prompt even further this time I'm
going to say what's the best way to
center a div element horizontally and
vertically using CSS so I'm providing
more context I'm saying I want to know
what the best way is I'm also being more
specific I'm saying I want specifically
a div element and I want to Center it
both horizontally and vertically and I'm
also specifying the technology that I
want chat GPT to respond with which is
CSS this results in a similar response
so it's still suggesting that we use
flexbox or css grid but this time it
gives us some pros and cons for flexbox
as well as some sample code and some
pros and cons for grid so you can see
how even the slightest tweak to a prompt
can result in in very different outputs
from GPT let's look at another example
I'm going to start with the really broad
prompt how do I use reduce with this
prompt GPT responds by explaining that
reduce is a function that takes two
arguments but looking down a little
further you'll see that because we
didn't specify a technology it is
providing an explanation of reduce in
Python followed by some sample code on
how to use reduce in Python so here's a
small challenge for you think about how
you would engineer The Prompt if you
wanted a JavaScript example think about
how you would engineer The Prompt if you
wanted to understand what javascript's
reduced method is used for in other
words some use cases and also think
about how you would engineer a prompt if
you were a beginner and you wanted to
make sure that GPT responds with simpler
instructions and also think about how
you would engineer a prompt if you
wanted GPT to incorporate all three of
these assumptions go ahead and pause
this scrim go to chat gpt's public
interface face and play around with
prompting based on these assumptions and
when you return I will show you my
inputs and
outputs welcome back hopefully you found
that exercise to be helpful let's have a
look at how I engineered my prompts
first I'm making sure to provide context
be more specific and use technical terms
by specifying the technology I want to
use the specific method that I want to
learn about and I'm asking GPT to
provide examples of what I might use the
reduce method for GPT responds with a
definition of what reduce is followed by
a stepbystep example of how you can use
it great it also very helpfully provides
the example in a single code block so
that I could copy and paste this into a
scrim if I wanted it also goes on to
provide a more advanced use case of
reduce which is when it takes in an
array of objects and transforms that
array of objects into something else in
my next prompt I again am specific about
what language that I want to discuss the
reduce method in but this time I'm
asking for its use cases specifically so
again it provides a definition of reduce
and then provides five instances in
which it might be helpful to use reduce
so calculating the sum of an array of
elements finding the product of an array
of elements counting the occurrences of
elements in an array flattening a nested
array and transforming an array of
objects into an object with a specific
structure which happens to be the
example that it showed us last time and
in my final example I'm again asking for
javascript's produce method and I'm
asking gbt to explain it to me as if I'm
a beginning developer just learning how
to code I'm also asking for a very
specific example I want to know how I
can use reduce to calculate the total
price of several items in a shopping
cart you'll notice that the result is
that GB output is a much longer and more
detailed explanation of reduce using
slightly less technical language it
reminds us what arrays are and carefully
explains how the reduce method works by
going through each element in the array
one by one and applying a function that
you define it then provides a
step-by-step shopping cart example just
like we asked for pretty cool this has
been just a few examples of how we can
use specificity technical language and
context to tweak gpt's output to get as
close as possible to the information
that we desire we've seen how to use
these strategies to get information
about code and code samples now join me
in the next scrim to discuss how we can
use these principles to use GPT to
produce usable code I'll see you
there let's talk about using specific
Technical and contextual prompts to get
GPT to generate code as an example let's
start with a very broad non-specific
non-technical prompt with no context and
that prompt is how do I create a form
GPT trying to be as helpful as possible
responds that well there's lots of ways
to make a form you can use a form in
HTML for a web page you can use Google
forms or you can even create a form in
Microsoft Word then also continues to
try to be helpful by providing examples
of how you might get started creating a
form using all three of these Avenues so
here is a challenge for you think about
how you would improve this prompt so
that it is specific Technical and
provides context and here is your
context you want to create a form that
displays the reverse of whatever the
user inputs into the form go ahead and
pause go to gpt's public interface and
play around with how you would engineer
a prompt to produce this code and when
you return I'll show you the prompt that
I
crafted
welcome back were you able to create a
form here's how I did it I started by
saying please create a form in
JavaScript with one input that accepts a
string and on submit prints that word to
the web page in Reverse so I'm being
specific about what I want the form to
do I'm specifying that I want the form
to be in JavaScript and that I intend to
use it on a web page GPT responds with
the HTML and JavaScript that I need to
complete this
form let's quickly copy and paste this
code in and see if it works so I have my
HTML and my JavaScript and let's run
this and because I put my JavaScript
into a file called index.js I'm going to
have to make sure to go ahead and change
that in the HTML it
generated this is another way that we
could improve the specificity of the
prompt by the way is we can say please
assume that we have a Javascript file
called
index.js and that way GPT will change
its code samples accordingly but let's
just go ahead and change it manually
this
time and see if this
works I'm going to type this is
backwards and we'll submit and there we
go whatever we enter into the field is
printed to the page backwards exactly
what we wanted let's look at another
quick example this is a less broad
prompt with a little little bit of
context I'm saying please show me an
example react component and GPT responds
making the assumption that I'm starting
from ground zero so it's saying first
make sure that you have node installed
on your system and use create react app
navigate to the project directory then
open the source folder and put this into
appjs and it gives us an example of a
little greeting component it then tells
us to run our create react app that we
need to PM start so it's trying to be as
helpful as possible but this may end up
being way more information than we're
looking for and that is another thing to
keep in mind when engineering as
specific prompt and providing the proper
context so take a moment to think about
how you might improve upon this prompt I
want you to try to engineer a prompt
based on all three of the following
assumptions you want GPT to assume that
you already have a react project set up
let's assume that you want to see an
example of use effect in this example
react component and let's also assume
that you want an atypical example and
not the same examples that you see
everywhere like a counter component that
simply increments a number by one every
time you click a button or a react
component that simply says hello world
so go ahead and pause the scrim now go
to gpt's public interface and engineer a
prompt that addresses all three of these
assumptions I'll see you when you get
back welcome back hopefully you were
able to engineer a prompt that got you
some helpful results let's have a look
at my prompt so my prompt is please
create an example react component that
takes at least one prop and demonstrates
how to use hooks like use State and use
effect now I've done something that can
be incredibly helpful when prompt
engineering I'm specifying what I don't
want GPT to respond with so I'm saying
the example should not be a typical
hello world example like a counter or a
greeting and I'm saying assume that I
have already set up a react project so
this time given the specificity of our
prompt GPT skips all of the setup
instructions that it included before and
it gives us this theme switcher example
which arguably could be the third most
common example that is used when
teaching react but that's okay it didn't
give us what we specifically said we
didn't want so this is an area where we
could play around and try to improve
this prompt a little more pi get an
example that's perhaps a little more
interesting but other than that it's
given us what we wanted we have a react
example that uses use State and use
effect we also get a pretty good
explanation of how the example is
working and some instruction on how to
use it in our existing react project
when it comes to prompt engineering
specifically for coding or learning to
code specificity technical language and
providing context will take you a long
way but there's still a bunch more to
learn and a ton of new examples to try
and all sorts of ways that you can tweak
your prompts to get as close to exactly
what you want so I look forward to
seeing you in the next scrim where we'll
continue to talk about more prompt
engineering tips I will see you
there now for a quiz and a bit of
practice I really encourage you as
you're going through this course to
spend as much time as you can trying out
different prompts in chat GPT if you
need a link to open ai's chat GPT
interface I've included that right here
so keep in mind when you're actively
practicing rather than passively
watching the scrims you're much more
likely to retain the information I've
sprinkled challenges and opportunities
for practice like this throughout the
course so do take your time to get your
hands dirty like I said it's going to
really help you remember everything that
you've learned so we have a short quiz
question for you to answer and a few
less than ideal prompts that I'd like
you to improve based on what you've
learned so far go ahead and pause the
scrim now and work on the quiz and
practice welcome back hopefully
hopefully that went well let's go over
some possible answers our quiz question
is what are the three basic components
of an effective prompt and those are to
be specific use technical terms and
provide
context if we look at these suboptimal
prompts they are missing one or all of
these things so let's look at the first
one I need to Loop through an array help
how could we rewrite this so that it's
more specific uses technical terms and
provides context your answer is will
most likely be a little different than
mine but let me show you the prompts
that I came up with for this one I added
some context and Technical Language by
saying in JavaScript how can I utilize
the for each method to iterate over an
array of objects and extract a specific
property from each so I'm being specific
about the language I want to work in and
providing some context about what I want
to do for this second question I want my
website to look good on phones 2o my
prompt was what are the recommended CSS
media query breakpoints for for mobile
tablet and desktop views to ensure my
website is responsive across various
devices so again more specificity more
context and more specificity around
technical terms our third prompt is I'm
having issues bringing data into my
react app my prompt for this is how can
I use the use effect hook in react to
fetch data from a rest API endpoint and
store the results in a local state using
the used State hook this is maybe a
little more specific than I needed to be
so if you find your s aren't quite so
specific that's totally fine as long as
the basic elements are there you're more
likely to get more precise results and
that's it for the quiz in practice to
take this a little further you can try
entering both the vague prompt and the
prompt you came up with into chat GPT
and note the differences between the two
the vague prompt might accidentally be
correct or somewhat correct or help you
get to your desired answer but generally
a more precise prompt is going to save
you time by yielding more precise
results
this is one of my very favorite tips
because there is so much that you can do
with it so let's talk about all the ways
you can fine-tune gpt's responses by
controlling the length and format
especially when you're trying to learn
something new with GPT these are some
really effective ways to get as much or
as little information as you want in
some formats you may not have thought
about before let's look at some examples
I could request information like this I
could say provide a brief two step
explanation of creating a custom
JavaScript event and GPT responds with
an explanation that has exactly two
steps I can say something like please
compare CSS grid and flexbox
highlighting their main differences and
use cases in a tabular format so I'm
requesting the response as a table and
gbt responds with this great little
table that compares grid to flex box in
the way that I've specified it's pretty
awesome I can also get extremely
specific so I want to know why inner
HTML should be avoided why we shouldn't
use it so I'll ask GPT to summarize in
exactly three bullet points why in HTML
shouldn't be used I also want each
bullet point to be followed by a short
explanation and a code example of what I
should use instead here's gpt's response
I get exactly three bullet points we
shouldn't use inner HTML due to security
risks performance ISS issues and
accessibility issues it can cause
problems for screen readers and other
assistive Technologies GPT recommends
some other things that we can use and
shows us an example as we've requested
this is a really good example of how
granular we can be when controlling the
length and formatting of a response from
GPT a question that we get asked a lot
here at scrimba is how much Java Script
should I know and be comfortable with
before I start learning react let's see
what GPT thinks my prompt is please list
the five most important JavaScript
Concepts a beginning developer should be
comfortable with before learning react I
want the response to be brief though so
I'm going to be really specific about
the kind of response that I want so I'll
go on to say please provide a one
sentence explanation of each concept and
one sentence about why it is important
for learning react let's see how it
worked out this is fairly close to what
we requested we have exactly five
JavaScript Concepts variables and data
types functions and scope arrays and
objects troll flow and conditionals and
asynchronous programming and promises
and then we get a one- sentence
explanation of what that JavaScript
concept is and why it is important to
learn for react so for example
understanding how to work with
asynchronous code using callbacks and
Promises is crucial for handling events
making API calls and handling State
updates in react this is an exactly what
we asked for but it's pretty close and
if we wanted to we could go back and
refine The Prompt a little bit if that's
what we wanted to do I can also ask GPT
to create flowcharts so here I've asked
please create a flowchart describing how
to submit a poll request using GitHub
and it creates a text-based flowchart
outlining all of the steps from forking
the repository all the way down to
creating a new pull request on GitHub
and choosing which branches I want to
merge if you ask me this is a really
cool way to begin to understand a
concept with a ton of steps I can also
ask GPT to create pseudo code please
create pseudo code in the form of code
comments describing how I can write a
react component that displays the time
in a user's local time zone I'm
requesting that pseudo code in the form
of code comments because I've discovered
that when I ask for pseudo code it tends
to give me code that sort of looks like
Python and what I want are step-by-step
instructions for how I can code this
function myself and code comments are
what's most effective for me so let's
see what GPT did in the form of code
comments it's broken down into small
steps with even more specific
instructions so this would be great if I
really want to make sure that I'm
writing my own code but I desire some
stepbystep help to help me think through
how I might structure my code here are
even more examples I can control the
length by requesting a definition in one
paragraph or one sentence I can even
specify that I want a response in so
many words or less this is also one of
my favorites I can request a tldr of a
topic which if you're not familiar
stands for too long didn't read it's
basically another way of saying give me
a short explanation so I can say tldr
explain the difference between let and
const in JavaScript I can request a
specific task in a specific technology
but request the solution without using
any external tools or libraries I can
ask for explanations in the form of
analogies and metaphors I can also copy
and paste GPT some code and ask for an
explanation via code comments on every
line explaining what the code does and
finally here's another one that I use a
lot and we will see more of later I can
prompt GPT with in your response please
only include the code that needs to be
modified and this is really helpful if
you're having GPT generate some more
complex code for you it does have a
tendency to print out all of the code
every single time and this way you can
ask for just what needs to be modified
we will talk much more about this in
later scrims now that we've looked at
quite a few examples please take a
second to think about how prompting to
control the length and format of the
response can be helpful to you go ahead
really quick think of a topic that
you're unfamiliar with or that you've
always meant to look more into and ask
GPT for an overview in whichever format
you feel would be helpful and definitely
use the examples on this list or the
other examples that we've looked at for
inspiration for example I was recently
contributing to an open- source project
that uses Redux which I'm not very
familiar with pause now give it a try
and when you come back I will show you
yet another example of how I prompted to
get the response in the exact format I
was looking
for welcome back hopefully that was a
really good exploration so as I said I
wanted to know more about Redux so my
prompt was please explain how to use
Redux step by step using a simple code
example such as tracking whether or not
a user is logged in so I'm asking for a
response in a step-by-step format using
a specific code example and then I'm
getting even more granular by requesting
one sentence that explains each step
then once GPT has provided me with a
step-by-step explanation of reduct with
the code sample that I've specified I
wanted to make up an acronym for me
that's going to help me remember all of
the steps I need to remember to use
Redux if you're at all familiar with
Redux or have ever tried to learn it
there are a lot a lot a lot of steps
let's look at the response I was able to
get GPT says here's a step-by-step guide
on how to use Redux with a simple code
example to track user login status thank
you that's exactly what I asked for
we'll use the acronym carts as a
reminder of of the steps it's a pretty
good acronym it's easy to remember it's
an actual word so then using This
Acronym it breaks down the steps we're
going to create a redex door do some
action craters and then here is the one
sentence explanation of each step that I
requested it goes on and shows me the
rest of the steps and then at the end it
says remember the acronym cards to help
you remember the steps for using redex
in a react application and it goes on to
summarize the acronym that I requested
prompting GPT in a way that controls the
format and length of its responses is a
super powerful way to use GPT both as a
learning tool and as a timesaver when
coding up features this is really worth
getting comfortable with so I really
encourage you to just take some time
right now before moving on to the next
scrim to choose a few coding Concepts
you've always meant to look into a bit
more and explore them with GPT using a
variety of formats definitely refer back
to the slides and to the list of examp
this is going to get you familiar with
all the many ways you can prompt GPT to
share information with
you time for a bit of a challenge you're
going to design some prompts to build a
small application that generates haikus
if you're unfamiliar with haikus it is a
poem with a 575 syllable structure so if
we take a look at this example I asked
chat GPT to generate a houp for me that
was about prompt engineering and this is
what it came up with crafting questions
sharp guiding thought with Precision
answers clearer shine if you were to
count the syllables in this poem you
would find that the first line has five
syllables the second line has seven
syllables and the third line again has
five syllables your task will be to
prompt chat GPT to write you code for a
very simple application where you'll
push a button here in the mini browser
and it will generate and display a
randomly generated Hau so I've given you
three vague suboptimal prompts that I
want you to improve you'll improve these
prompts using all of the techniques that
you've learned so far and then use those
prompts with chat GPT to generate some
code you can then copy and paste the
code you've generated right here in the
scrim into this JS file to make sure
that your prompts have yielded code that
does what you expect let's quickly read
over the prompts that you'll be
improving the first is make some lists
of phrases for a haiku I want them to be
about artificial intelligence the second
is combine the phrases into Haiku and
the third suboptimal prompt is make the
hius show up when I press a button I've
asked for hius about artificial
intelligence here but feel free to
generate Haus about whatever subject you
want rainbows unicorns math it's up to
you also these prompts don't give you a
ton of hints as far as how to structure
your code so if you need some help on
that you can go ahead and take a look at
this hints MD file for some guidance
before you get started I have one final
important disclaimer you may have
noticed that the title of this scrim and
this file is Huish gener and that is
because for reasons unknown chat GPT is
not great at counting syllables and will
sometimes produce phrases that are a
syllable or two off for the purposes of
this challenge we're not going to worry
about that but if you want to ensure
100% accurate results you can manually
count the number of syllables in the
list of phrases that you generate or ask
chat gbt to break down each line and
count the syllables for you have fun
with this go ahead and pause the scrim
now and get started on the
challenge welcome back I hope you had a
fun time generating hauz let me show you
the prompts that I came up with the
first prompt that I wanted you to
improve is make some lists of phrases
for a h cou i want them to be about
artificial intelligence here is my
improved prompt generate three
JavaScript arrays for a hou generator
where each array represents a line of
the ha cou the first and third arrays
should contain phrases with five
syllables and the second array should
contain phrases with seven syllables all
the phrases should relate to artificial
intelligence here are the lines for my
Huish generator that chat BT came up
with we have an array of phrases for
each line of the poem The phrases for
line one contain more or less five
syllables the phrases for line two
contain more or less seven syllables and
the phrases for the third line of the
poem contain more or less five syllables
the second prompt that we needed to
improve was combine the phrases into a
ha coup this is my improved prompt for
that write a JavaScript function to
randomly select one string from the
three arrays of strings and return a
combined string where each Haiku is on a
separate line this prompt yielded the
following function so we have this
generate ha cou function that takes in
three arrays containing phrases for
possible ha cus there is a get random
line function that takes in an array and
chooses a random item from that array in
this case a random line for a poem and
it then calls the get random line
function three times one for each line
of the poem it saves each line into its
own variable and finally returns a
string containing the three randomly
chosen lines
concatenated with a line break in
between each the third and final prompt
that I asked you to improve was make the
haikus show up when I press a button my
improved prompt for this was create a
button in JavaScript that when clicked
triggers the generate Hau function and
displays the Haiku to the web page from
this prompt I was able to get an
eventless listen ER that is attached to
an element with the ID of generate
button and when clicked it calls the
generate hi cou function and sets the
text content of an element with the ID
of hi cou output to the results of the
generate hi cou function it also
generated a couple of lines of HTML
which I will copy and paste into my
index we have a button with the ID of
generate button and a
pre-tagged when I click it I get random
Haus fantastic in this Grim you've built
a haiku generator application in just
three prompts if you've spent any amount
of time with chat gbt you may be
thinking well this could have been done
with just one prompt and well that's
most likely true when you're using chat
gbt it's good practice to always be
thinking about how to split projects
into smaller tasks more on that in the
next scrim excellent work on this
challenge or in the form of a hi cou
challenge met with Grace generator
speaks in verse student claims their
place see you in the next
one with the right prompts AI is
surprisingly sometimes frighteningly
capable and because it's so capable our
first impulse might be to stretch it out
as far as it can go how much can I make
it do how few prompts can I get away
with can I get a whole app with a single
prompt the answer is yes you probably
can but the results might be a little me
think of it this way say you're building
a brick wall like this adorable little
penguin if you were to build it by hand
you'd probably go Brick by Brick right
making sure that each element was in its
place before moving on to the next one
you wouldn't throw all the bricks and
all the mortar into a pile and smear it
around until it sort of resembled a wall
but one of the pitfalls of AI is that
it's tempting to do this with code it's
really tempting to hand AI a list of
instructions and try to mold whatever it
spits out into a workable application
this is why I advocate instead that when
you build with AI you break everything
down into small smaller chunks and that
means the tasks that you're trying to
accomplish with AI as well as the
instructions that you prompt the AI with
and the features that you choose to
build I also can't stress enough the
importance of taking time to read and
understand the code that AI generates
along the way so why should you do this
breaking it down into smaller steps is
going to be better for manageability for
Learning and understanding the code and
for isolating bugs and other issues it
is possible to get AI to spit out a
whole react app in one go but the more
complex the thing you ask for the more
likely there are to be errors and
inconsistencies and the less likely you
are to understand the code or feel any
sense of ownership over it so it's
really easy to get trapped in a cycle
where you don't understand the code
you're working with you ask chat gbt to
debug it it solves one issue but
introduces another and on and on until
the brick wall crumbles and you storm
away frustrated am I speaking from
experience yes let me show you an
example so what I'm after is to build
this budget tracker basically in the
form you can put a budget title your
budget how much of that budget you've
actually spent and then you can add it
to this nice little visualizer that
represents your budget versus how much
you've spent as a progress bar here's
what happens when I try to do this in
one big prompt so we're going to read
all of this really quick my huge prompt
is help me build a small react
application to help users visualize
their budget the application should
consist of a form with three inputs a
budget title a total budget and current
expenditures when the user submits the
form a progress bar should be added to
the page the progress bar should be
green if less than 50% of the budget has
been reached orange if more than 75% of
the budget has been reached and red if
100% or more of the budget has been
reached the app should keep track of the
total budget and total expenditures and
display a large progress bar with this
info at the top of the page users should
also be able to delete and edit progress
bars create Json for four example budget
progress bars and assume I already have
react project set up this is a very tall
order there is a lot of stuff and the AI
is smart but telling it to do all of
this at once is going to make it more
apt to forget things so I ended up with
something like this as you can see this
somewhat resembles what I asked for we
have some budgets we have the total
budget and the amount spent we have a
little form and it does work but the
following things are wrong there are no
progress bars and that is because AI
forgot to set a height for the progress
bar so they're there but they're
invisible it also completely ignored my
request for ADD and delete functionality
which is honestly understandable because
that adds a great deal of complexity to
the application and it ignored my
request for a main larger progress bar
that represents the total overall budget
not spectacular results so take a second
and think about how you would break this
down I don't think that there's
necessarily a right answer here I think
it's going to depend a lot on how your
brain works and how you tend to build
code in the first place but some
suggestions are you could break the task
down by structure and style as then you
could do all the HTML and then the CSS
and then worry about functionality this
is a react app so you could build each
component one by one you could
concentrate on certain features or any
other number of possibilities but let me
show you how I did it I'm going to
concentrate first on building the budget
form component my prompt is helped me
build a small react application that
helps users visualize their budget make
sure it meets the following requirements
and then I'm breaking down tasks into a
list making a list makes it a little bit
less likely that AI is going to leave
things out so this is another component
of breaking things down into smaller
tasks within a prompt so I say number
one and include a form component with
three inputs and number two I'm going to
describe the functionality when the form
is submitted add the new budget to an
array of budgets here's what the output
look like and this is what we end up
with so it's pretty simple so far but I
can add a budget let's say rent and it
simply adds the budget with the total
amount of the budget and how much we
spent now I want to make the form look
nice so I'll say add styles to the form
with three bullet points it should be
responsive I want the form fields to be
stacked and the fields are styled
similar to bootstrap Fields but don't
use any outside libraries and that
yields some CSS which I will go ahead
and drop into the CSS file and that is a
pretty nice looking form with just a
couple of prompts I'll now move on to
displaying my budgets in a progress bar
so using this same format I'm going to
say each progress bar component should
have the following and then I'll make a
list I want to display the budget title
the budget versus how much we've spent
below the progress bar and then the
color scheme that I wanted for the
progress bar so if you're close to
reaching your budget it'll be red if you
haven't spent much of your budget it'll
be green then I specify that my progress
bar should be thick with rounded Corners
this yields some progress bar CSS which
I will put in my CSS file it also gave
me some progress bar code which I
already have in this file called
progress bar and finally inside of my
app it instructed me to rewrite this map
function to use the progress bar rather
than simply mapping through the array so
we'll go ahead and replace all of this
code and what's happening now is we are
collecting the budget data from the
budget Forum we're adding it to this
hook that is keeping track of all of the
budget objects inside of an array we're
then mapping through the array of
budgets and passing that information to
a progress bar that has all of the
progress bar Styles and information
about how we want to display it let's
run and add a budget and there we go we
have a working budget tracker that
displays a progress bar I can then
continue to iterate on this project in
small steps for example I can ask it to
create some dummy data so that we can
see what our application looks like with
a bunch of budgets add that here here
are our budgets with a bunch of dummy
data and then finally I can take care of
a couple of bugs as you can see the
progress bar gets too long if you go
over budget so for our entertainment
budget we've overs spent by $50 making
the progress bar too wide I also want to
to change these harsh colors so I'll ask
it for one final task before we wrap up
this scrim the width of the progress bar
should never exceed 100% if the spent
amount exceeds the budget amount make
the budget SLS spent progress bar text
red display the spent budget text as a
dollar amount and use dark pastel colors
for the progress bars so let's copy and
paste the refactored code and run and
this is pretty close to what I had in
mind this gr has been about building
iteratively and breaking up complex
tasks into smaller steps as the the task
you complete with AI grow more complex
remember to ask yourself how can I keep
breaking it
down let's pause for a second to take a
quick quiz to help things stick a little
better read through the quiz questions
and answer them to the best of your
ability go ahead and pause the scrim now
and start working on
it welcome back so why can it be helpful
to break down a project into smaller
steps even if the language model is
smart enough to handle it my answer
answer is that overall it makes the
project more manageable it helps you to
more thoroughly understand the code and
more effectively discover bugs and other
issues it helps you avoid a situation
where you have a lot of code that you
are unfamiliar with and not sure how it
works because Chachi BT has generated
all of it for you the second question is
how would you break down the following
prompt into smaller tasks and as I said
you didn't have to worry about actually
writing the prompts I just wanted you to
think about how the app could be broken
down in a highlevel way to be built Inc
mentally with the help of chat GPT
there's going to be a lot of variations
and answers here because everyone's a
little different but here's how I would
break it up I would start with the pet
list and layout part of the application
whether or not I wanted the list to
display as a gallery or as a straight
vertical list and all of the components
that I might need for that then I would
worry about the responsiveness of the
pet list and
layout I then move on to accessibility
finally I would look at filtering the
list of pets building a pet detail page
and finally I would worry about styling
this isn't all-inclusive of course and
some of this could be broken down into
substeps but hopefully that gives you a
general idea so that's it for this quiz
thanks for taking the time and great
work when you're using a language model
like chat GPT to help you build an
application it might be tempting to
assume that when you ask chat GPT to
produce something for you and it fails
that the language model is simply not
capable of that task and sure there are
plenty of things that chat gbt is not
great at like the time I tried to get it
to write fiction GH not good but I'm
sure with the right prompts you could
get close to chat GPT doing even that
because making a few tweaks to your
prompts can make a huge difference this
is a strategy called iterative prompting
iterative prompting is the process of
prompting evaluating the ai's response
and either revising your prompts to get
as close to your desired outcome as
possible or clarifying what you want
with a follow-up prompt let's look at a
couple of simple examples I have an HTML
table that has some information about
board games let's say that it represents
the inventory for a store called Roll
With It games I start with the prompt
please create a product web page based
on this HTML table and the result looks
something like this it isn't bad it's
simple bold colors I like the addition
of a buy now button I think that makes a
lot of sense but what I really had in
mind was more of a gallery layout where
each board game is a card in a row of
cards also if you were to look at the
code example you would notice that this
is all hardcoded and the HTML and CSS is
Allin one file which isn't exactly what
I want so I'm going to iterate on my
prompt tweaking it to be a little more
specific I kept my original prompt
please create a web page based on this
HTML table now I'm going to add use a
responsive Gallery format where each
product is a tile then I'll say convert
the data in the HTML table to Json and
use JavaScript to Loop through and
display each game so that will take take
care of my problem with it being
hardcoded here's where things start to
get a little messy it starts by
converting my HTML table to Json but
then if you look at the code it gives me
everything is still in the same file
which is fine I didn't specify that I
wanted it to be split but it also added
a second games array of objects I have
this whole Json file that isn't being
used so there are sort of two ways that
you can iterate on a prompt and this is
the first one wherein I have clicked
this edit button and simply changed the
prompt and had the AI completely
regenerate a response if you're
unfamiliar with the interface you can
then use these right and left arrows to
Rifle through all of the prompts and
responses which can be pretty handy in
some cases and by the way this says
three out of three because on my second
attempt chat gbt errored out and I had
to regenerate because of that revising a
prompt like this can be really helpful
if what you generated is not close to
what you want however in this case let's
take a look at the output so in some
ways this is closer to what I wanted I
have each game as a tile I have some
issues with responsiveness that I would
need to work on as you can see because
there are four cards one is kind of in
the middle of the second row which may
or may not be what I want but I've also
lost the buy now buttons and the color
scheme that I was kind of fond of so
maybe I didn't really want to start all
over what I can do is I can go back to
my original prompt so I'll click back
through to my original prompt and I can
continue the conversation with this
prompt and instead of revising it I'm
going to add a follow-up prompt and my
follow-up prompt will break down all of
the changes that I want to make so as a
list I would like the AI to break the
code into separate CSS JS and HTML files
I want to extract the data from the HTML
table into a Json file and I want to
create a function to Loop through the
Json and display each game as a card in
a responsive Gallery format and so
through iterating with a follow-up
prompt here's what I end up with I have
the best of both worlds which is the
gallery format that I was after plus the
buying Now button and the green color
scheme so to wrap things up remember
that iterative prompting is all about
trial and error plus a bit of creativity
and persistence if you follow this
process prompting evaluating the output
and either revising or writing a
follow-up prompt it's going to make it
that much easier to achieve smoother
more predictable
results let's learn a little prompt
engineering Inception using AI to
optimize and improve your prompts and
then feed those prompts back into the AI
for the most effective results the
strategy involves two stages the first
is asking chat GPT to interview you
about your needs so it can then craft
and optimize prompt for you based on
those needs stage two is using the
prompt to prompt chadt to maximize the
quality of your desired output let's
look at an example my first prompt will
be I'm going to give you a prompt and I
want you to help me optimize it ask me
clarifying questions then suggest a more
effective prompt that will yield a more
accurate and detailed output chat GPT
says absolutely I'd be happy to help you
optimize your prompt please share it
with me I'll then give it the prompt
please give me some example code for
react accordion menu now that I've asked
chat gbt to interview me it will come
back with a list of clarifying questions
that's going to help me be more specific
about what I'm looking for and this is
cool because not only will it result in
a more refined prompt but it's also kind
of like a built-in brainstorming session
so Chad jpt says to optimize it I'd like
to ask a few clarifying questions would
you prefer that the accordion menu be
made of class components or functional
components using hooks are there any
specific features you'd like the
accordion menu to have like multiple
sections open at the same time
animations or accessibility features
will there be any specific data
structure for the content of the
accordion or will it be text only and
finally would you like to use a specific
styling strategy followed by some
suggestions for styling strategies that
I could use I'm going to go down the
list and answer each question I want
functional components for my features
I'll say I want a smooth open and close
animation I want only one one section to
be open at a time and I'd like to use
the open Sans Google font I want my
accordion to accept Json data and I also
going to ask the AI to generate some
dummy data for me and finally I'll tell
it I just want to use a regular external
stylesheet I've given chat TBT a lot of
detail about what I want here this
strategy has helped me provide a lot of
clarification on what I actually want
chat gbt responds could you provide me
with example code for react accordion
menu that meets the following
requirements followed by a summary of
the requirements based on my answers
from the previous prompt so I can now
dump this back into chat GPT as a much
more specific contextual refined prompt
so that's what I'm going to do I'm now
going to prompt with this optimized
prompt chat gbt responds with some
example code for an accordion which I
have copied and pasted into the scrim so
let's take a look we have the dummy data
we asked for we are using a functional
component with hooks and a regular
stylesheet just like we asked for and as
you can see this is a pretty good
looking accordion menu for a couple of
minutes worth of work let's do a little
review of what we've just done I'm going
to come over to my accordion. jsx file
these are the steps I just went through
to optimize my prompt first I prompted
chat gbt to ask clarifying questions
about my prompt I then answered chat
gpt's clarifying questions and when chat
GPT returned an optimized prompt I then
fed it back to chat GPT and the result
is hopefully a more finely tuned code
snippet that includes all of the
features that you were after definitely
try this strategy out for yourself I
find that it works really well when I'm
trying to do something relatively
complex or when I'm murky or undecided
on the details of what I need a function
or react component to
do time for a quick review and some more
practice we've just talked about a
strategy for optimizing a prompt and we
did this in three steps your first
prompt should be an overview of what
you're trying to accomplish and a
request for chat gbt to ask you
clarifying questions your second prompt
will be answers to chat gbt's clarifying
questions and after you answer the
questions chat gbt will output and
optimize prompt which will then feed
back into chat GPT let's practice this
by instructing chat GPT to help us build
a simple modal window if you're
unfamiliar a modal is generally a
secondary window that opens up on hover
or buttonclick on a website so think
about a popup payment form or a box that
pops up where you might enter a username
and password but I'd like you to do is
starting with this prompt show me a code
snippet for modal in react go to chat
GPT I've included the link right here
and follow the steps to create a more
optimized prompt then just for fun I set
up this scrim so that you can enter your
code into this model. jsx file just to
test it out and see if it works modal
windows can have a lot of options and
those will be up to you but my advice
would be to keep it as simple as
possible for example I'm going to prompt
for a modal that displays a box of text
on button click and that's really all
it's going to do go ahead and pause the
scrim now and start working on this
challenge all right we are back let me
show you the prompt that I came up with
my prompt was I'm going to give you a
prompt and I want you to ask me
clarifying questions to help optimize
The Prompt suggest a more effective
prompt based on my answer here's the
prompt show me a code snippet for modal
in react and here are the clarifying
questions that chat gbt asked me yours
will probably be a bit different but the
general idea should be the same that GPT
wants me to clarify if I want a
functional component or a class
component in react do I want the model
to be styled with play CSS scss or a
specific Library like styled components
do I want the model to open and close
based on a button click are there any
specific content types that I want
inside the model like text images or a
form do I want want any transition
effects for when the modal appears or
disappears and am I using any State
Management tools like Redux or do I want
to use local component State here are my
quick answers to these clarifying
questions I want a functional component
I want to use an external CSS stylesheet
yes I want the modal to open and close
on buttonclick just displaying text is
fine for now I want my modal to use a
simple fade in and Fade Out effect and
finally I just want to use local
component State based on the answers to
these questions here is the optimized
prompt that chat gbt came up with that
prompt is provide a react functional
component code snippet for a modal that
utilizes an external CSS stylesheet the
modal should display text content and
open close based on a button click it
should have a simple fade in-out
transition effect and manage its
visibility using local component State
just for fun let's look at the modal
code that chat GPT output based on my
optimized prompt so I'll go to model.
jsx and copy and paste that code in so
we have a clickable button that says
toggle modal and then we have some jsx
for the modal code that's based on the
local component state is open which our
toggle modal function toggles from True
to false notice that we do have
hardcoded modal info here so that's
something that we'd want to iteratively
improve upon but this is certainly a
good start chat GPT also provided some
CSS which I will copy and paste into the
CSS file so we have some styles to make
sure it has a semi-transparent
background when it's open and some key
frames for some simple transition
effects let's go ahead and open the mini
browser and run this to test it out got
my toggle modal button and when I press
it there we go a very simple modal in
this challenge we've learned how to get
chat GPT working for us to create more
effective prompts well
done let's talk about a really
interesting way to plan learn and create
with AI it's called role-based prompting
role based prompting is a strategy in
which you ask a language model like chat
jpt to put on a costume so to speak you
instruct the AI to take on a specific
Persona while interacting with you for
example you might start a prompt with
act as a or you are a and as we'll see
you can have it act as a variety of
things that will help you as a software
engineer like product manager software
architect or even career coach which
we'll talk about in a later scrim let me
show you how you can use role-based
prompting to plan out basically an
entire application I'm going to start by
asking the AI to act as an expert in
system design and architecture and
advise me on how to design the front end
of a react application that helps users
keep track of how often to water and
fertilize their house plants this is a
big comprehensive list it's kind of
Broad and not super helpful right now
but it will be in just a moment so my
next prompt in the same chat window is
going to be you're now a product owner
tasked with Gathering requirements for
this project what features andun
functionality should this application
have ask me clarifying questions if
necessary this is a really good strategy
when you need AI to help you brainstorm
or when you want to try to get a
different perspective than you might be
able to come up with on your own I'm
instructing the AI to actually interview
me about what I want out of my project
the AI immediately assumes the Persona
of a product owner and says it's my
responsibility to ensure that the
product we're creating truly meets the
needs of our end users great it then
makes a list of of basic functionalities
and ask me some questions so do we need
user accounts what kind of plant
information should the app include water
and fertilizer reminders should there be
a catalog of plants to choose from and
what about user preferences so this is
all good to think about but very
overwhelming at the moment so I'm going
to prompt again kind of drill down I'm
going to say let's concentrate on plant
information first that's the second one
on the list and the question was what
type of information should be tracked
for for each plant for instance do we
need to track only watering and
fertilizing schedules or should we
include other details like sunlight
needs optimal temperature plant species
Etc so as part of my prompt I will say
let's include the nickname and image the
watering and fertilizer frequency the
last time that the plant was watered the
last time it was fertilized and also an
additional place for notes the AI then
provides fleshed out requirements for
the plant information functionality as
well as some information about the
overall plant display the date should be
localized the information should be
presented in an intuitive and
userfriendly format that's great but
this is all still a little bit broad to
be helpful to me so I going to prompt
again to drill down even more I'm going
to now ask the AI to assume a third role
I'm going to say I now want you to act
as a product manager please wrate user
stories based on the above requirements
if you're not familiar with what a user
story is it's basically a way to explain
how a software feature should work from
the perspective of a user or a customer
so notice that I did not ask for a
specific number of user stories so the
AI comes back with 13 user stories which
is very thorough so you see we have as a
user I want the app to calculate and
display the number of days since each of
my plants was last watered or fertilized
so that I can easily see when they need
care next that's great another example
is as a user I want to edit notes I've
added for each plant so I can keep them
current and useful this is great there
are a lot of good ideas here but this is
still a huge long list and as a software
developer I'm still overwhelmed I don't
really know where to start I'm going to
do another role based prompt you are the
product manager of this application
please advise me as a software engineer
which stories are most necessary to
create an MVP for prototyping and demo
purposes so basically this prompt is
asking the AI to pair down the list for
me what are the most important things
that I should concentrate on first so it
picks six user stories assigning a
nickname uploading an image of a plant
setting the watering and fertilizing
frequency and so on so if I'm looking to
build a demo or a personal project to
put in my portfolio or something I now
have a really well-defined place to
start which is pretty cool now if I want
some more advice on where to start how
to structure what technologies to use
I've had AI help me determine and plan
so much of my application at this point
that I can do one final role-based
prompt we're going to bring it back to
the software architect and say act as a
software architect and give me advice on
how to design the front end of a react
application based on the following user
stories I'm then going to copy and paste
the six user stories that the AI just
determined for me and get some advice
based on these user stories that I've
worked with the UI to create the chat
GPT then suggests a component hierarchy
to start with as well as some advice
about all sorts of things like State
Management handling images calculating
dates and some user interface and ux
stuff so this will give me some really
good ideas about how to get started and
then here is one of my favorite things I
can now do another rooll base prompt
that says you and I are a software
engineering team discuss the
requirements for the first three user
stories and turn them into tickets to be
entered in jira and now ai say sure
let's break down these user stories into
individual tasks that can be created as
tickets in jira so I have my user story
I have the tasks that go with it and the
acceptance criteria so with role-based
prompting I've gotten some ideas about
how to structure my app I have
determined the most important features
I've determined what I need for an MVP
and I've generated tickets for jir now I
can be Off to the Races building my app
so this has been a scrim about how to
leverage AI to plan out an application
using ro-based prompt engineering now
this method may not work for software
engineering teams building software out
in the real world it's often much much
more complicated than that and there's a
lot of back and forth and a lot of cooks
in the kitchen when it comes to building
soft soft ware but if you're looking to
build a portfolio of personal projects
for the purposes of getting a job for
example or if you're a oneperson startup
company this can be a really effective
way to use chat GPT as an idea engine
and as a partner in brainstorming so I
hope you found this useful happy role
playing let's do a quick review of
role-based prompting followed by a
little exercise role-based prompting is
when you use phrases like act as a or
you ra to prompt chat gbt to assume a
certain role while assuming the role of
an expert you can prompt chat gbt to ask
clarifying questions and you can also
ask chat gbt to assume a role to help
you define Technologies determine key
features and write user stories when
you're planning a project so here's the
scenario for the exercise you want to
use chat GPT to help you build an MVP
for a booking website that displays
information on hotel resorts an MVP if
you aren't familiar stands for minimum
viable product and it's way to describe
an app that has the most barebone
features that you'll need in a working
application so you can think about like
a very simple prototype of Airbnb or
Expedia with no bells and whistles all
you can do is view information about
Resorts even an MVP of this type is
going to be fairly complex once you
think about all the pieces so we're not
going to try to get chat GPT to build
this site we're just going to get a
little bit of practice using role-based
prompting to plan an application so once
again you're going use role-based
prompting to get advice from chat GPT on
how to create an MVP for a booking
website that simply displays information
on hotel resorts you'll want to start by
writing a prompt that will yield a broad
overview of all the things you might
need to think about for an MVP chances
are chat gbt is going to point out a lot
of things that you'll need to think
about when planning this type of
application so just pick one area of
focus and prompt chat gbt to keep
assuming a role and ask you clarify
ifying questions to help you drill down
into the area that you want to
concentrate on planning and once you've
drilled that down use chat gbt to create
five user stories for that area of focus
don't forget to use role-based prompting
here as well go ahead and pause the
scrim now and start working on this
challenge welcome back I hope you came
up with some great user stories let me
show you my prompts The Prompt I started
with is I want to build a simple booking
website for resort hotels act as a
product manager and help me identify
features I should include in an MVP as
expected chat gbt came back with a lot
of information going to copy and paste
that in and as you can see there is a
whole lot to think about here user
authentication search functionality
Resort listings booking process the list
goes on and on so the one that I'm going
to choose to focus on is Resort listings
so let me actually get rid of all of
this other stuff so that we can better
focus on Resort list listings here's a
prompt I use to get chat GPT to help me
narrow down what I want to do with
Resort listings my prompt was let's
focus on Resort listings acting as a
product manager decide on the five most
important features and write user
stories for them as requested chat gbt
gives me five user stories that includes
seeing a Details page high quality
images the ability to read reviews and
see ratings clear information on room
availability types and their pricing and
so on in this Grim we've narrowed down a
plan to start working on a complex
application and written some user
stories in just a few prompts this can
be a really helpful strategy for
starting to plan an application and
especially if you're a new developer
just starting out and trying to maybe
build portfolio projects it can also
help you realize the scope of a project
that you have in mind and help you
narrow it or expand it accordingly so
great job on this
challenge
one of the most effective ways to
engineer a good prompt for chat GPT is
to show and not tell in other words
prompting with examples of what you want
chat GPT to do let me show you a couple
of examples I'm in a prompt chat GPT to
write a function to Total an array of
numbers and return the value as a dollar
amount rather than fiddling with this
prompt and wondering if it's clear
enough and if GPT is going to be able to
parse what I'm saying I'm going to
include with my prompt an example input
and an example output so my input is an
array of numbers some with decimal
points and my example output is
172.5 formatted as US currency GPT then
responds with this function and even
gives us a line of code with our example
input so that we can test it so let's
copy and paste that into the scrim and
see how it works after I pasted it I'll
run and as you can see using the example
input that we provided the output is
17250 which is the output we expected
just for fun let's try some different
numbers so five and five should be $10
great what if we just have one number in
here that'll be
$8 and if we have an empty array we get
back $0 great let's look at one more
example first I'm going to ask chat GPT
to generate some dummy Json data for me
I specify that I want it to be for music
events and I'm going to give it an
example of all of the properties that I
want my Json to contain so band name the
event date and time ticket cost venue
and genre I'll then request that it only
generate dummy data for two bands
because I don't want the Json data to be
too long GPT responds with some Json
data I'm going to go ahead and comment
out this first example and copy and
paste this Json data looks good we have
a little error because this isn't a Json
file but that's okay we'll fix that in a
second I then copied and pasted that
Json data back into a prompt and my
prompt is considering the following Json
data so considering this example Json
data please write a function that will
take in this data and return a new
object where the event date time is
converted to a human readable format I
then include an example that has an
additional property and you'll notice
that actually made a little typo here I
write formatted data time when I meant
formatted date time but as you'll see
chat gbt was actually smart enough to
correct this for me so this is my
example output I want the event date
time to be converted to this nice human
readable time wherein instead of a
jumble of letters and numbers you can
see that it says nicely may5 2023 at
8:00 p.m. GPT responds with this format
event data function it puts my data into
a variable for me and logs it out let's
copy and paste this into the scrim and
see how it did get rid of my example
Json and let's run and you'll notice
that it is taking in this array of
objects that has five properties band
name genre event date time ticket cost
and venue and it is returning an array
of objects with six properties because
despite my type of it has added a
property called formatted date time and
that is the power of prompt engineering
with examples if there is a way that you
can show chat GPT exactly what you would
like your output to be I highly
recommend you do so now stay tuned for a
fun little challenge where we'll prompt
with examples to build a Seltzer flavor
generator I'll see you in the next
one welcome back prompt Engineers here
is a fun little challenge that will give
you some practice prompting by example I
don't know about you but in my area of
the world flavored seltzer water is
extremely popular and there are hundreds
of flavors ranging from pretty simple
like black cherry or pomegranate to kind
of out there like raspberry Rose
hibiscus cloudberry and mango Cherry
bliss all the way to downright bizaar
this is a real seltzer water flavor it's
called Yeti Mischief they also have one
called unicorn kisses and one called
Dragon Whispers I've had all three and
of course I don't know what a real
dragon whisper tastes like but I guess I
can believe that it tastes like a fruit
bomb with a tropical punch it was good
for this challenge you will prompt GPT
to create a function that generates
random salzer Water flavors some
examples might be funky raspberry
pineapple wacky strawberry whipped cream
Zippy pineapple mango the format that
you want to follow here is adjective
followed by a flavor followed by another
flavor and the flavor titles should be
capitalized so make sure that the code
that you generate with chat GPT
capitalizes these flavors you'll want to
give GPT example inputs and outputs the
function that you produce should take in
an array of adjectives and an adjective
is a describing word like funky or Zippy
or blue and it should ALS o take an
array of flavors so pineapple mango
strawberry whipped cream all examples of
flavors go ahead and ask GPT to generate
these two arrays the array of adjectives
and the array of flavors you decide if
you want your flavors to be delicious
weird bizarre icky inedible it's your
choice have fun with it and then finally
test the function that GPT outputs and
if it doesn't work or if GPT doesn't
produce exactly what you've asked for
keep iterating on your prompt until you
get the result that you want grab a
mermaid song flavored Seltzer and get
started I'll see you in the next scrim
with the
solution hey there this is the solution
to the flavor generator challenge your
challenge was to prompt GPT to create a
function to generate weird wacky or
delicious random salzer Water flavors in
the following format an adjective
followed by a flavor followed by another
flavor here's some examp examples funky
raspberry pineapple wacky strawberry
whipped cream Etc you were also to
ensure that chat GPT gave you the output
you expected by giving example inputs
and outputs let's take a look at the
prompt that I wrote create a function
that suggests new Selzer Water flavors
I'm then going to be very specific about
the arguments that the function should
accept so the function should accept two
arguments an array of flavors and an
array of adjectives the function should
pick two flavors at random and return a
new flavor in this format adjective
flavor flavor I give it an example input
which is two arrays one of flavors and
one of adjectives and then in my output
I make sure to follow the format I
specified an adjective followed by two
flavors let's take a look at the code
that chat GPT generated based on this
prompt copy and paste it into my
index.js file as you can see it
commented things nicely for me which is
helpful it tends to do this randomly so
it can be really helpful to specify
whether or not you want comments when
you're asking GPT to generate a function
for you so inside the suggest new flavor
function we have a function to get a
random index we then use the function to
get a random number between zero and the
length of the adjective array and save
it to a constant and then we use that
random number to choose an adjective
from the adjectives array we're then
doing something something very similar
to select the two flavors we're using
the get random index function to get two
random numbers that we can then use to
choose something out of the flavors
array now it seems confusing at first
why it decided to save one to a const
and one to a let but that is because on
the next line of code we're looking at
both of the random numbers that were
chosen and we're ensuring that they
aren't the same so we don't end up with
a double flavor like wacky apple apple
or something because that wouldn't make
sense it's really cool that chat GPT
checked for this on its own but this is
definitely a potential bug that you
would want to consider so finally it
selects two flavors from the flavors
array and returns a string in my
requested format adjective flavor it
also provides me with some example usage
which is great so let's go ahead and
call this
function run and open the console and
see what we end up with I want to make
sure that I am locked fogging out the
result of this function let's run again
we get sour grapefruit orange Tangy
Orange grapefruit cool Orange grapefruit
so it looks like we're getting the
result we expected which is great but
now I want chat TBT to generate me some
fun flavor ideas so next I prompted
please generate 20 sweet or dessert-like
foods for the flavors array I'm again
going to give it some examples like cake
pineapple and whipped cream then I say
generate 20 wacky and fun adjectives the
adjective array for example tart fresh
and Smokey keep in mind that this prompt
is based on the fact that I have just in
the last interaction as chat GPT to
generate a function for me so I'm not
referring to that function I'm counting
on it to remember the code that we're
talking about but there are many
instances where you might want to refer
to the function as part of your prompt
so as you can see it gives me a list but
that's not what I want I want to be a
lazy programmer and I want these as
arrays I I want to turn them into a
raise myself so I'm going to update my
prompt and be a little more specific and
deliberate so I'm going to explicitly
say please generate two JavaScript
arrays the first one I want 20 sweet or
dessert like foods for the flavors array
and then I give my examples and then
number two 20 wacky and fun adjectives
for the adjective array with some
examples like buttery luscious and
artisanal this time it does exactly what
I ask it to do it gives me 20 flavors
and 20 weird adjectives let's copy and
paste these into the scrim so I will
replace these shorter arrays and let's
run see what we come up with Whimsical
banana whipped cream interesting zesty
caramel Cherry vibrant Cherry mango all
right so we've got the result that we
wanted but I see a little issue here I
want these flavors to be capitalized
quickly I'm going to say please write a
function that capitalizes each word in
the Seltzer flavor this is something
iterative and incremental I'm again
going to provide an example so here is
an all lowercase sour orange apple and I
want the first letter of each word to be
uppercase so it gives me this
capitalized word function so we'll copy
and paste this code in right underneath
our other
function and it did provide me with an
example usage but instead of using that
I'm going to come down here and I'm
going to wrap my suggest new FL Flor
function into this capitalized word
function and that's how we'll test to
see if it works I'll run Zippy cake
cinnamon interesting flavor and with
that my salzer water generator is
complete showing versus telling and
using examples when it comes to working
with chat GPT is incredibly valuable
it's a great skill to learn so thanks
for practicing with me hope you enjoy it
let's continue on to the next prompt
engineering
tip in earlier scrims I talked a little
bit about the dangers of chat GPT
hallucinating hallucinating is language
models tendency to sometimes simply make
things up things that can sound
perfectly plausible and true but just
aren't chat jpt can rather randomly make
up facts misquote people or give false
information so what I'd like to do in
this scrim is show you an example of a
time that chat GPT hallucinated while I
was trying to work with it as well as
talk about why GPT hallucinates and what
you can do if it hallucinates or how to
try to prevent it from happening so one
day I was working with chat GPT to
create an interactive timeline which is
basically a web graphic that you can
click on it will show certain years on a
timeline and you can click on that year
for more information when I asked chat
GPT to help me with this it immediately
gave me an accordion menu which was not
exactly what I wanted so here was my
follow-up prompt what suggestion do you
have for a more Dynamic user interface I
was hoping for some something a little
more graphically interesting than a
simple accordion menu notice that my
prompt is not very specific it's pretty
open-ended and it's almost like I'm
asking the language model to tell me
what it thinks like I'm asking it for
its opinion rather than requesting it
perform a concrete task and I think that
might be one of the reasons that it
began to hallucinate so its response was
for a more Dynamic and Visually
appealing user interface I suggest using
a horizontal timeline layout with a
sliding effect so what it's suggesting
is something that is a photo Carousel
where you can cycle through a collection
of photos or other information by
clicking on right and left arrows so it
suggests this open-source Library called
Chronos slider notice it even gives me
the GitHub URL and it claims that this
library is lightweight and very easy to
integrate it then gives me instructions
and Sample code but guess what when I go
to this GitHub link I get a 404 it
doesn't exist when chat TPT does make
mistakes it can be pretty good at
correcting itself so I'm going to ask it
to confirm its own information my next
prompt was I get a 404 error when I try
to visit the Kronos slider GitHub
repository can you check the URL and
then chat gbt is like oh apologies for
the confusion I made an error in my
response it seems that the Chronos
slider Library does not exist and then
it suggests another Library which does
in fact exist and not only does it exist
but it turns out to be a little closer
to what I was actually looking for so
that's what happened Chachi BT
completely fabricated a library and
instructions for how to use it let's
talk about why this happens why do
language models hallucinate can be for a
few reasons it can be limited or
incorrect training data a
misinterpretation of your prompt or and
probably most likely for the example
that I went through it has to do with
the way GPT works I've heard GPT
described as an incredibly sophisticated
autocorrect basically the way that it
comes up with responses is that it tries
to determine the likelihood of the next
word given a sequence of words so it's
trying to optimize and guess what the
next word is going to be and that
sometimes causes the model to prioritize
coherence over correctness in other
words it will occasionally pick
something that sounds good over
something that's actually true at this
point I have spent many hundreds of
hours with chat gbt and it's only
hallucinated a few times to my knowledge
so this isn't an error that happens
constantly but it is something that is
helpful to be aware of here are some
things you can do when chat TPT
hallucinates as I showed you you can
prompt the model to double check its
response and or you can confirm the
response for yourself sometimes it can
be good to do both breaking questions or
tasks into smaller chunks can be really
helpful and it's been shown that the
smaller that you break down the tasks
the more accurate the response whether
that means into smaller prompts or
breaking stuff down into lists of things
as well as encouraging the model to show
its own work or Justify the choice
choices that it's making in the context
of code as we'll see later sometimes
that can mean add code comments
explaining what you've done and why
you've chosen to do it that way and then
finally you can rephrase the question to
ask it in a different way be more
specific or provide more context so
those are some tips to mitigate tat GPT
hallucinating tat GPT is an amazing tool
that if you remain just a little bit
critical of the information that it's
giving
you congrat ulations go ahead and give
yourself a nice pat on the back because
you've learned a number of strategies
for more effective prompt Engineering in
this section we covered how to refine
prompts with specificity context and
Technical language we learned how to
gain more refined control over the
length and formatting of the ai's
responses we've covered breaking down
tasks and prompting iteratively
optimizing prompts rule-based prompting
and prompting by example I've included
in this scrim a markdown file with a lot
of the examples that we covered and you
can go ahead and use this as a reference
if you'd like to save it you can click
on this little gear here and download
the file as a zip you can then open it
up in a text editor like VSS code next
up in the next section of the course
we'll go over ideas and strategies for
using AI to accelerate your coding
workflow I'll see you
there now that we've gotten comfortable
with all the facets of effective prompt
engineering let's explore some ways AI
language models can help you be a faster
and more effective developer here's just
a short list of some of the ways you can
use AI for web development you can use
it to generate project ideas plan
projects write user stories and even
Jura tickets you can generate code and
code Snippets generate mock data debug
get code review and suggestions for
refactor convert code from one format to
another like from python to JavaScript
for example you can write tests and
documentation and find that you can
learn new technologies and advanced
topics faster than ever before in this
next section of the course I'm going to
show you a wealth of examples and ideas
for how you can use prompt engineering
to generate code in a precise and
incremental way as well as how to use AI
to explore learn and study web
development topics so let's go let's do
it as we've seen in previous scrims you
can accomplish a lot with a well-crafted
prompt by describing in detail exactly
what the code should accomplish
generating code from pseudo code is
another effective strategy to maximize
your specificity and fine-tune your
results pseudo code is an informal way
to describe what your code should do in
plain English and that could mean a
bulleted list of procedural steps or
very simplified code that doesn't follow
the syntax of any particular language
and this tip is going to be especially
helpful if you're wanting to accomplish
a coding task in a specific way if
you're trying to generate code in a
language you're unfamiliar with or if
you simply want to code without worrying
about precise syntax so let me show you
an example let's say I wanted to write a
function to find a book in a book array
by the book's ID my prompt will look
something like this I'll start by
specifying that I want the prompt to be
written in JavaScript now I'll go ahead
and start my pseudo code with something
that pretty much looks like JavaScript
I'll say I want to take two arguments a
book array and an ID but now instead of
writing a function I'm just going to do
some quick pseudo code so I'll say for
each book in the book array if book. ID
equals the ID that we're passing into
the function then return that book from
the array else return an error object
with a message notbook found that's my
prompt and here is the result as you can
see this is pretty much exactly what I
asked for we are looping through the
book array we're comparing each book ID
to the ID that we're passing into the
function and if they match we're
returning that book and if we don't find
trying to match we're returning an error
object no book found I then want to be
able to test this function so I'm going
to write another quick prompt that is
just generate some funny book mock data
to test this function chat GPT returns
some fun book data and I can test my
function by passing in this books array
and an ID of five so let's run and open
up the console and that results in the
book with an ID of five so we know that
this function is working great so that's
one method of pseudo code that we can do
just basically it looks like code but
with no formal syntax but I can also
write pseudo code that is a little more
conversational so for example here is
another prompt where I'm basically
asking for the same thing in a longer
form write a JavaScript function find
book by ID so I'm calling it find book
by ID instead of get book this time and
this function should take two arguments
book array and the ID for each book in
the book array compare each book array
ID ID with the past in ID if found
return book if not found return error
object sorry no book found I'll copy and
paste the function that chat GPT
generates and as you can see it is
almost exactly the same We're looping
through the books comparing the IDS
returning the book if we find it and
returning an error if we don't find it
I'll call this function with the same
array of books let's try a different
number how about book number four great
and let's try it if we enter a book ID
that doesn't exist we get an error
message perfect we've covered in this
scrim how you can quickly create and
test a function using pseudo code to
more finely controlled output if you'd
like some practice here in index.js I
have a few suggestions for functions you
can prompt AI to generate with pseudo
code so you want to write detailed
pseudo code for the following functions
and prompt jat GPT to write those
functions for you we have a function
that adds two numbers a function that
adds all the numbers in an array a
function that that looks for a user ID
in a user array and returns an error if
not found a function to count vowels in
a string and a function that finds the
highest number in an array go ahead and
practice prompting with pseudo code if
you want to and as I said before this is
a really helpful strategy if you're
trying to generate code in a language
you aren't familiar with if you want to
have more control over how a function is
written or maybe you're still new to
coding and want to work through the
logic yourself and not have the AI do
too much
work
for precise communication with chat GPT
you can create a pseudo language which
is basically an agreement that you are
going to prompt chat GPT in a certain
way and you expect it to respond in a
certain way let me show you what I mean
I'm going to come over here to this
counter MD file and here is the prompt
that I shared with chat GPT I want to
build my own react component library
with common components like form Fields
nav barss and an accordion menu then I
break down two instructions create a
pseudo language similar to markdown that
will help me quickly describe a react
component so that you can convert it to
example code respond with the template I
can use as well as an example component
keep the template and the component as
simple as possible I added this last
line here because in my experimentation
chat tobt did tend to over complicate
things here's the template it gave me
this is our agreement of how I'm going
to Define react components so that chat
GPT can provide me with the code for
these components I'm going to name the
component I'm going to Define it State
props what it should render and the
event handlers that it has in this
format under State I'll Define any and
all state variables with their initial
values under props I'll list all the
props that my components will take with
the prop type I'll describe what I want
the component to render and I'll list
event handlers with a Handler name and
the description of what the Handler
should do here is the example that chat
GPT provided for me so it gave me a
simple counter example we're going to
keep track of one piece of State called
count with with an initial value of zero
as a prop we're going to take in an
increment value which is a number the
increment of the count so instead of
incrementing by one we could increment
by five or 10 or 15 or 7 or whatever we
want to do the component should render a
button that displays the current count
and each click increases the count by
the increment value which is the prop
that our component is taking in finally
we have an event handler called handle
increment and that increases the count
state by the increment value this is a
fairly detailed description of what we
want this component to do so let's see
how it works I'll go to my counter. jsx
file here's the code chat gbt generated
I'll go to index.js and we'll import
this component finally we'll render it
in our app component run and see if it
works excellent we have established a
pseudo language with chat GPT to
describe in detail the components that
we want to build this does have its
limitations chat jpt is only going to
remember this agreement for so long so
you will have to periodically mind it
but this is just one more way that you
can communicate with chat GPT with
Precision let's try creating another
component I'm going to go to my navbar
markdown file and copy and paste in my
pseudo language template I want to fill
this out so that I can prompt chat GPT
to create a simple navigation bar for me
before I show you how I filled this out
I'd encourage you to pause the scrim for
a second and fill this out yourself
think about how you would describe how
to build a nav bar you can copy and
paste this in the chat gbt and say hey
this is the pseudo language I want to
use to create react components and I
want you to create a navbar component
pause the scrim now and when you're
ready come back and I'll show you how I
did
it welcome back I hope you found that
educational let me show you how I
approach this I'm going to start with my
render statement because for me it makes
sense to describe first what I want the
component to do so I'm going to say that
the component accepts an array of
objects each representing a link in the
nav menu I want each object to contain
URL name and I'll give an example here
like home about or contact us Etc and of
course we want the URL we want our Navar
component to render the list of links I
know I want to keep track of which link
is currently active so I'm going to have
a piece of State called active link and
that's going to keep track of the index
of the menu item so I want the initial
value to be zero I want my nav bar to
take in an array of Link objects as I've
specified here I'm going to refer to
that as nav links and the prop type will
be object then I'll handle clicks on the
link and when a nav menu item is clicked
I want its index to become the active
link a better way to say this might be
update active link with nav menu item
index let's look at the code that
resulted from this prompt I'll go to my
navb bar. jsx file and paste it in we
have this Navar which is pretty much
exactly what I described it Loops
through an array of navlink objects and
for each renders a list item with a link
which when clicked sets that link to
active let's import this into appjs and
try it out before we can test it out
we're going to have to come up with some
links to pass as a prop to the Navar I
prompted gbt to generate this for us I
asked it for some learning to code
themed links here's what it came up with
we'll pass the nav links array of
objects to navbar as a prop just like
that run here's a simple nav bar that we
generated using a pseudo language with
chat GPT this could use some styling of
course but I think it's a pretty good
start welcome to another challenge where
you are going to develop a pseudo
language with chat GPT to help you gener
generate forms first you'll prompt chat
gbt to create a pseudo language for
creating HTML forms and secondly if you
like the suggestions go ahead and use
the pseudo language to create a form can
ask for adjustments if necessary and if
the pseudo language it comes up with is
too complicated reprompt with an
instruction to keep it simple I've
noticed that this is an area where chat
TBT tends to want to provide you with a
very comprehensive solution it's going
to account for everything you might
possibly want to do with the pseudo
language which is great but for the
purpose of this exercise we want to keep
it as simple as possible so it might be
beneficial for you to instruct Chach BT
to go for Simplicity go ahead and pause
now and start working on the
challenge welcome back I hope that went
well for you here is my prompt create a
pseudo language that will help me
quickly describe to you how to provide
sample code and styles for an HTML form
respond with the template I can use as
well as a sample element here is the
pseudo language that chat gbt came up
with so we have a form we can specify an
action a mage method and the types of
inputs that we want and within inputs we
can specify a type label any attributes
and styles and down here you can see we
can also specify styles for the form
itself so this looks pretty good to me
I'm now going to scroll down a little
bit and I'll show you the example that
it gave me so we have a form where the
action is submit form we're going to
post and it has a text input for a
username and a submit button and then
also some styles to give it a border
I'll show you the result when I use this
pseudo language to make a prompt that I
fed right back to chat GPT I'm going to
go to the index.html and I'll go ahead
and paste my form code here and into my
CSS file I will paste the CSS let's go
ahead and run and test this out and
there we go a nice simple little form in
just a few steps using this strategy you
can create a session with chat gbt where
you can use this template over and over
to quickly and precisely create a number
of web components just keep in mind that
chat gbt's memory is short and you may
need to remind it of your template after
every seven or 10 interactions or so
thank you for trying out this challenge
fantastic
work there's a lot to think about when
you're writing a function there's so
many edge cases that you need to account
for and it can take a lot of practice to
be able to identify what those edge
cases are luckily this is something that
chat GPT really excels at we can use it
to identify edge cases and generate
inputs so that you can test your
function against those edge cases this
strategy can be super informative and
educational especially if you're new to
programming so let's take a look
starting in my remove dupes MD file I'm
first going to prompt chat GPT to write
a JavaScript function that takes in an
array and returns a new array with any
duplicate items removed I'll now jump to
my remove dupes JS file and here's what
that function looks like the function is
creating a set out of the array because
set automatically removes duplicates and
then we're turning it back into an array
using array. from so basically we're
going to pass the array into set set
removes all the duplicates then we're
converting it back into an array and
saving it to a variable called unique
array and then returning that array
where all the duplicates are removed
returning to remove dupes let me show
you my second prompt and that is list
eight edge cases this function should
account for and provide test cases for
each you may want to ask it for all the
edge cases or however many edge cases
you want I specify eight edge cases just
to keep it from going on and on and on
this is gpt's response and it did
include a definition of each which I
erase just for the sake of brevity so
the edge cases we want to account for
are an empty array an array with a
single element an array with all
elements that are the same an array with
different types of elements like num
strings and booleans an array with
nested arrays Chad gbt sort of disclaims
here that the function that it gave us
won't work as expected because
JavaScript only allows comparisons of
simple data types so so if we wanted to
check for duplicate arrays we would need
another solution the six case is an
array with objects then a non-array
dealing with what the function should do
if it receives an input that's not an
array at all and finally arrays with
special numbers like not a number and
infinity it also included with this
response an additional disclaimer the
function provided doesn't handle nested
arrays objects or non-array inputs
that's just fine for our purposes so
let's return to remove dupes DJs here I
made an additional prompt because I
wanted the output to be in a specific
format I asked for the edge cases in a
single code block just for ease of copy
and pasting and I ask it to denote the
edge cases as part of the console log so
here's an example of what I want each
test or each Edge case to look like
before we call the function inside the
console log with whatever our test case
is I want what we're testing for to be
denoted as a string here are the test
cases as you can see they're in exactly
the format that I requested that's great
so let's head to index.html really quick
and I'm going to add remov dupes DJs as
my script Source let's return to remove
dupes JS run and see how we go and open
the console here are all of our tests
and our results this is really helpful
cuz if you take a look at an array with
a single element it's passing into one
and we can see that our result is an
array with one inside of it so we're
dealing with that edge case as expected
but take a look at non-array inputs in
which we're passing in a string and
you'll notice that we have two T's a
capital t and a lowercase T which this
function considers two different
characters so they are not considered
duplicates depending on your purposes
that's an edge case that you might want
to account for let's do one more example
I'm going to go up here to count
frequency. JS and paste in a prompt as
well as the function that chat gbt
responded with so I prompted write a
JavaScript function that counts the
frequency of characters in a string this
function creates an object it checks
through every character in a string if
it finds the character it increments the
character count by one and if it doesn't
find it it creates it in the Char count
object what I'd like you to do is pause
the scrim now and ask GPT for five edge
cases and then test this function
against those edge cases when you return
I'll show you my prompt and output I'll
see you in a
sec welcome back hope it went well here
is my prompt my prompt is what are five
edge cases this function should account
for please list the edge cases followed
by a single code block with tests for
those edge cases here's what it came up
with because I have already requested a
similar task chat GPT is going to give
me a very similar format to before which
is great that's exactly what I want you
may have needed to tweak it a little bit
that is completely okay I'm going to
return to index.html and change my
script source to to count
frequency run and see our result in the
console you can see the five test cases
for these edge cases and their results
as I said I think this strategy can be
pretty helpful to almost anybody but
especially if you're new this can be
really really educational chat GPT can
really open your eyes to edge cases and
things that your function might need to
do that you may have never thought about
definitely use this to your advantage
and join me in the next scrim to talk a
bit more about test
cases language models can be extremely
helpful when it comes to testing your
code it's great at coming up with random
inputs with which to test your function
it can help you write tests using test
Suites like justest and can even help
you refactor based on those tests here
in my scrim I have this password Checker
function it checks if a password is
valid and a password is considered valid
if it has 10 or more characters includes
at least one capital letter and and
contains one special character like a
star an ampersand a dollar sign or an
exclamation point say I just wanted to
call this function with a bunch of
different inputs to get a feel for how
it will handle different inputs so I can
ask for some really simple tests call
the following function with 10 test
inputs and console log the results and
then I have an example of what I want
the console log to look like I want to
call the function with a random input
and I want a label that lets me know
what input went into this function and
then of of course I reference in my
prompt the function that I want to test
let's take a look at gpt's response as
you can see it's made up 10 random
passwords some of which are valid and
some of which are not let's open the
console and run this and we see the
output of our various tests as I said
GPT can also generate tests for specific
test Suites and head over to my is even
JS file we have this really simple
function that takes in a number as an
input and uses the modulus operator to
to divide it by two to determine whether
or not it's even if I wanted to generate
some just tests for this I can prompt to
chat GPT something like please write
eight tests for this JS function using
just it spits out some functions using
the just syntax and also makes some
really good assumptions about the types
of input and edge cases that we should
test this function with for example it
tests with zero with positive numbers
negative even and odd numbers and so on
now say that I wanted to generate some
test that look like just but I want to
be able to run them quickly in my
browser or in a scrim to do that all
prompt please write 10 tests for this
function that look like Jess but that I
can run in my browser and then going to
reference the function that I want it to
write the test for and it responds
certainly here's an approach for a very
basic just like testing setup that you
can run in your browser's console we
have a test function that is going to
run a test callback and print the result
of each test with a check if it passes
and an X if it doesn't pass we'll take a
closer look at this in a second but it
goes on to make a bunch of just like
tests for all sorts of inputs decimals
negative decimals positive even numbers
negative odd numbers and even a string
and note down here that it says
JavaScript is a dynamically typed
language and does type coercion so 12
the string is coerced to 12 the number
which means that the string 12 will
return true as our function is currently
written let's have a closer look at the
response in the scrim copy and paste
here we have a couple of helper
functions that help us to create a
justlike environment and a bunch of
tests so I'm going to go to my
index.html I'm going to make sure that
the right script is uncommented then we
can return to is even and run these
tests all of our just like tests have
passed but once again this draws my
attention to the fact that the string 12
will be coerced into the number 12 and
therefore will return true as my
function is written so based on the
results of my tests let's say that I
decide that I actually don't want that
to happen I want my function to only
accept numbers as input so to GPT I'm
going to prompt please refactor my
iseven function so that string inputs
are invalid it suggests a couple of
Alternatives one where it returns false
if the input is not a number and one
that will throw an error if the input is
not a number with just a couple of
prompts I've been able to generate a
test suite and refactor my function to
cover more test cases based on the
results of that test Suite I'm going to
choose this first alternative which will
return false if the input is not a
number let's go back to the scrim and
I'll comment out our old function and
copy and paste in the new function let's
run the test again and now this last
test doesn't pass let's scroll down to
this test and I'm going to change this
because I now expect that is even will
return false if the input is a string
and so I would expect that when is even
is called with the string I would expect
that to be false I can run again and all
of my tests are passing this has been a
few ways that you can use a language
model to generate all sorts of input
data and tests and also refactor quickly
and with just a few
prompts in this little challenge you'll
jump in and use chat GPT to test a
function and generate some edge cases
especially for you new developers out
there this is great practice getting
familiar with all the different
possibilities your functions may need to
account for so here we have a small
function that takes an array and a chunk
size and returns a new array of
subarrays for that chunk size so here's
a little example we have this array
containing the numbers 1 2 3 4 we ask
for a chunk size of two so this function
then splits up the array into two arrays
with two items each so the first thing
I'd like you to do is go ahead and read
through the function make sure that you
understand what it's doing then ask chat
GPT to generate some test inputs for
your function just so that you can make
sure that it's working correctly then
you'll ask chat GPT for five edge cases
go ahead and read through those edge
cases that it generates and pick a
couple that you want to revise your
function to account for some of the
things that may involve infinite Loops
so don't jump right in running the edge
cases be sure to read through them and
revise the function first once you've
chosen a couple of edge cases you'll ask
chat GPT to revise the function
based on those edge cases and you'll
want to make sure to instruct chat GPT
on how you would like to deal with those
edge cases whether that's returning
humanfriendly errors or returning false
or returning one single error saying
something went wrong it's up to you how
you would like to handle errors so go
ahead and end pause now and start
working through these
steps welcome back let's go ahead and
generate some test cases I'm going to
delete this example test case we have
here and my prompt was call this
function with three test inputs and
console.log the results and I included
the function in my prompt here are the
test cases that chat GPT came up with we
have three test cases the first is an
array with nine items and we're asking
for a chunk size of three and our
expected output is that we split this
array into three chunks of three items
each in the second we have some strings
and we want a chunk size of two but
since we have five items we end up with
two items being chunked together in an
array and then one item by itself and in
the third test case we are asking for a
chunk size of one so each item in the
array ends up in an array all by itself
so that looks good let's go ahead and
now generate some edge cases going to
scroll down so we have a little bit of
room and here was my prompt kept it
simple generate five edge cases this
function should account for and again I
copied and pasted the function along
with my prompt chat gbt suggested
following edge cases if the input array
is null or undefined so if we get a null
instead of an array if the chunk size is
zero or negative that's going to cause
an infinite Loop because if we look at
our function we're incrementing I by the
size of our chunk each time so it won't
increment and we'll keep going and going
and going not exactly what we want and
then finally an edge case that we might
need to account for is if the chunk size
is null or or is not a number so for
example if we tried to input the string
two so I can see from these edge cases
that we're going to have a problem if
this function is called with types we
aren't expecting if the first argument
isn't an array or if the second argument
is anything but a positive integer based
on that knowledge here is the prompt
that I gave chat GPT to ask it to revise
the function my prompt was revise the
function based on the edge cases above
and I'm saying above here because I am
still in the same session with chat GPT
so I can count on it knowing the
function that I'm referring to throw a
userfriendly error if the first argument
is not an array or if the second
argument is not a positive integer so up
here I'm going to delete my old function
and replace it with my revised function
designed to deal with these edge cases
let's run this with our current test
cases looks like we're getting our
expected results with this revised
function so that's great now let's
scroll back down and uncomment these
edge cases so we can test them one by
one the first argument is null let's go
ahead and comment out these tests just
so we can see clearly the first comment
is null then we get the error the first
argument must be in Array that's great
test the second one this is the one that
was in danger of causing an infinite
Loop so instead we get an error that
says the second argument must be a
positive integer great that's what we
want now let's test what happens if the
chunk size or the second argument is
null we get the error about the second
argument
we get that same error if we try to
enter a string or anything that isn't a
positive integer in this Grim you've
practiced using chat GPT to test and
generate edge cases for a function so
really great job I hope this will come
in handy for the
future perhaps you've already discovered
in your experimentation with chat GPT
and other language models how easy it
can be to find errors and bugs in your
code for example I have this function
here and it takes some information about
blog previews and it uses it to
construct the HTML for a Blog preview
element so as you can see it takes in a
parent ID a card ID a card class a title
and some content and it makes HTML
elements that look a little something
like this however without having any
idea what this function does I could
copy and paste it into chat GPT and say
hey chat jpt what's wrong with this
function and it will indeed come back
with a list of everything that's wrong
with the function and it'll even correct
the mistakes for you in an easily copy
pastable code block don't look at this
for too long it contains spoilers this
is a perfectly great strategy as long as
your code isn't too complex what I'm
going to suggest you in the scrim is a
strategy to get language models to
communicate with you about errors in a
way that's going to let you better keep
track of the changes that chat GPT has
made so what I'd like you to do now is
prompt GPT to fix the errors in this
function by using these steps first run
the function and copy and paste any
error messages that you might get into
chat gbt along with the function then
I'd like you to ask the AI to explain
the errors to you as code comments this
can be a good thing to do because it
helps you keep track of what's going on
with your code and also making chat GPT
break down the changes and explain them
is going to help you minimize the
chances that it will make a mistake as
we've discussed the more you can break
down a task the better so go ahead pause
the scrim now and debug this function
welcome back hopefully you have some
nice blog previews in your mini browser
let me show you what I prompted so my
prompt was this function should return
the HTML for a new blog preview post so
I'm being really clear about what I
expect the function to do and I go on to
save but instead I'm getting the
following error and I copy and paste my
error and then I res followed with
please fix the errors and explain the
fixes with code comments chat TBT
responds with the following I have a
couple of problems in your code here is
the correct code but rather than
spitting out the corrected code or
giving me paragraphs of explanation
about what it changed it's right here
conveniently in the code comments let's
have a look at this in the scrim I'll go
ahead and delete my old code and replace
it with the new so I know after taking a
look at this that I forgot to call get
element by ID as a function and I didn't
pass anything into it I was trying to
append the content of the card
incorrectly and I had an error down down
here because of the way that I was
incorrectly calling get element by ID
chat TPT provided an extra paragraph
explaining what happened if you would
like to pause and read that you're
welcome to I actually found the code
comments a little hard to read so I
amended my prompt a little bit right
after please fix the errors and explain
the fixes with code comments I say
comment out the old code rather than
replacing it so I can better see how you
fixed it gbt then responds first with a
list of of issues that it addressed this
is helpful for understanding the problem
if you want to read through it but let's
see how this amendment changed chat
gpt's code output going to go ahead and
replace my function again and let's
close the console so now we have the old
code so this was our old line of code
and you see that we are assigning
[Music]
document.getelementsbytagname ID with
parent ID as an argument so this is the
corrected code and this way we can
compare the old code to the new code to
really understand what happened these
are just a few examples of how you can
tweak your prompts just a little bit to
get some really incremental and helpful
information out of chat gpt's responses
see you in the next
Grim AI can be so so helpful at
performing a variety of timeconsuming
detailed rote tasks and one of those
tasks is code conversion let's look at a
few examples I can give the AI an API
call and ask it to convert it to python
I can convert from language to language
for example this is an API call in
JavaScript and I'm asking chat jpt to
convert it to Python and this is what
that looks like I can also this is one
of my favorites convert CSS to Tailwind
I just have this blob of CSS as part of
my prompt chat GPT spits out some
Tailwind this came in really handy
recently when I was working on a project
the tailwind and I just wanted to make a
small change without having to learn it
right away real time saer I can also
convert CSS to a styled component in
react this is a really easy and often
accurate conversion that I have found
myself using a lot you can also convert
data from one format to another so here
I have a CSV file about sitcom from the
9s and I want chat GPT to convert it to
Json note that I do have to give it some
instructions so that the Json looks how
I want it to so I instruct it to
lowercase and concat the headers these
are the headers title main actors year
and average rating and if it is two
words I have asked chat chbt to convert
it to one snake cased word I've also
requested that it convert the main
actors's column to an array so I want an
array of actors and I've also specified
a type that I want for the year and
average rating columns and note that
this is also serving as an example of
what I want the column names to be and
quick as a flash I have converted the
data to Json with the specified property
names and types to review here are some
of the ways that you can use AI to
convert code from one thing to another
you can do language to language like
JavaScript to python file to file format
like CSV to markdown or to Json
framework to framework like converting a
react component to view this can be
really helpful if you're trying to pick
up a new framework maybe you have a
piece of react code that you're really
familiar with and you want to see what
that looks like converted to view so you
can start to use view there's a lot of
possibilities here and then of course my
favorite chat gp4 in particular is a
really great CSS converter CSS to scss
or to SAS or to Tailwind or styled
components again a lot of stuff you can
do I'm sure there are a lot more ways
that you can use this capability so keep
this in mind as you're considering ways
to make your development tasks
faster here I have a little application
that ideally when you click on this
Blast Off button will count down from
three and send this little rocket
blasting off into space unfortunately
the spaceship can't launch because it's
programmed in jQuery and Tailwind which
our scrim is not currently set up to
handle so here's your task you'll want
to prompt chat GPT to convert the jQuery
to plain JavaScript and the Tailwind
code in index.css to plain CSS then
you'll click last off to see if the
button works and if you've converted Ed
it successfully clicking the blast up
button should start a countdown timer
and the rocket ship should take off when
the countdown reaches zero go ahead and
pause the scrim now and work on this
challenge welcome back hopefully you
have liftoff here was my prompt to
convert the jQuery to plain JavaScript
pretty simple please convert this jQuery
to plain JavaScript and then I copied
and pasted the jQuery code in with my
prompt I'll go ahead and replace my
jQuery with my converted plain
JavaScript code we're selecting various
elements in our HTML adding an event
listener which starts a countdown on
click and also calls this rocket blast
function which uses the transform
property to move the rocket off screen
that looks good let's now go to our
index.css and convert this Tailwind code
my prompt here was also pretty
straightforward please convert this
Tailwind code into an external CSS
stylesheet I'll go ahead and replace
this Tailwind with my output from chat
jpt so you'll see that it has styled
everything nicely for me and now this
should work so let's click run and the
Blast Off button to see if this works 3
2 1 zero we have liftoff which means
we've used chachy BT to successfully
convert the code great
work it might seem like there's not too
much to say about documenting code with
AI you can use chat gbt to document a
function or other small bits of code
simply by copying and pasting the code
into the prompt and saying hey document
this for example take this little
function that creates SEO friendly slugs
if you're not familiar a slug is a
unique identifier for a link to a web
page and if it's optimized for SEO it
uses keywords and is often quite
descriptive here is our AI generated
documentation and as you can see this
function takes the title of the web page
and converts it to a slug you can see
down here in this little example that if
you pass it the string hello world it's
going to return hello world with no
capitalization and a hyphen between it
and this would become part of a URL to
uniquely identify the hello world page
so with chat gbt you can request
specific formats of documentation like
we've requested JS Doc and so it's going
to document the parameters that the
function takes as well as a description
of what it returns and its type it also
really neatly describes everything that
the function is doing so it converts the
title to lowercase it trims the leading
and trailing whites space it replaces
symbols and other non-alpha numeric
characters like commas or quotation
marks with hyphens and finally it
removes any leading or trailing hyphens
so that is some nice thorough AI
generated documentation another example
of a specific format you could ask for
documentation is prompting GPT with a
react component and asking how do I
document this using storybook and then
chat GPT will provide you with some
boilerplate code and you can start
having a conversation with it about how
you might do that so documentation is
pretty much as easy as asking for it so
Ai and language models really excel at
helping you create all sorts of
different types of documentation mostly
for smaller bits of code like isolated
functions and the like but here's a fun
little strategy for when you have a
longer piece of documentation you'd like
AI to help you with I'm going to prompt
chat gbt to interview me about my
thoughts and opinions on style
conventions and best practices and I'm
going to have it use my answers to
generate a style guide so my prompt is I
want to create a simple JavaScript style
guide guide ask me 10 questions about
best practices and style conventions and
use my answers to write a style guide
chat gbt says great here are some
questions it ask me 10 numbered
questions so pretty standard stuff like
do you prefer constant let over VAR
should we use semicolons what maximum
line length do you prefer single quotes
double quotes the dreaded tabs or spaces
debate Arrow functions and so on so the
way I'm going to answer this is I'm
going to create my own list from 1
through 10 and answer each and notice
that there are places in my answer where
I defer to the wisdom of others so for
questions five and six I say use
whatever is in GitHub style guide and
for number nine which is what is your
position on trailing commas and objects
and array literals I'm just going to say
go ahead and use whatever is in Google
style guide keeping in mind that this
will be information from chat gbt's cut
off in 2021 it is pretty cool though
that I'm able to pull in other sources
here to create my own style guide here
is the response to my answers it's my
own little style guide and now that I
have this file I could ask chat jpt to
convert it to markdown or something so
that I could put it on GitHub although
fair warning it doesn't do markdown
perfectly because the response text is
already formatting and that tends to
cause issues but the point is that in
just a few minutes I've generated at
least a starter document for a project
that most likely would have taken me
much longer if I were doing it manually
or maybe if I worked for a small team at
a busy startup I may not have ever done
documented anything at all as a
developer I've spent probably years of
my life pouring over code that is
minimally documented or not documented
at all so let's all keep this tool in
mind and put those days behind us happy
documenting AI can be a really powerful
tool for learning in a personalized and
interactive way in this scrim we'll talk
over a few quick tips on how to use a
language model like chat GPT to learn a
new topic or technology as well as
create highly tailored learning
experiences so for example you can use
chat TBT to summarize and explain info
in a variety of ways find learning
resources create a study guide Andor a
study schedule and also to test yourself
so let's go over these one by one and
look at some examples as far as
explanations and summaries go my advice
is to start broad by asking chat gbt
about a general topic then drilling down
into more and more detail as you're
exploring a topic you can instruct chat
GPC to summarize information and provide
explanations by specific Audience by
specific experience or skill level or by
asking for metaphors and specific
examples so let's say I've been studying
JavaScript and I'm ready to tackle more
advanced topics I can prompt something
like please suggest four Advanced
JavaScript topics that every junior or
intermediate developer should study the
result is a long list of advanced
JavaScript topics that I can study like
asynchronous programming Advanced Dom
manipulation design patterns functional
programming whole bunch of stuff so I'm
going to go ahead and pick one let's
concentrate on async programming here in
the explanatory paragraph it says
familiarize yourself with Concepts like
callbacks promises and async aake so
I'll just start with please tell me more
about callbacks explain the concept as
if I'm a beginner and include a code
sample so I'm requesting a specific
audience and a specific example we get a
nice explanation of callbacks that is
relatively simple and jargon free along
with a couple of simple examples let's
say I read through this explanation and
I still don't quite grasp it I can ask
chat TBT to use a metaphor or provide
use cases I still don't quite understand
can you explain callbacks using a
metaphor and can you provide a couple
more use cases the AI comes up with this
metaphor of a waiter in a restaurant
being like a callback you can go ahead
and pause the scrim if you'd like to
read through this and then it gives us a
couple more examples like reading a file
asynchronously and making an a API call
but what if I really really still don't
quite understand or more realistically
what if I want to start with a shortest
most simplified conceptual explanation
that I could get one strategy is to ask
chat TBT to explain something to you
like your five which is a really popular
thing to do on Reddit there's a whole
subreddit called explain to me like I'm
five so I'll prompt please explain
JavaScript call back functions to me as
if I am 5 years old AI comes up with
this example about you're a kid playing
with your toys you can can go ahead and
pause if you'd like to read through it
another helpful strategy is to ask for
an explanation based on a specific
audience or skill level or Persona or
all three as in this example you are a
senior engineer and I am a junior
engineer please explain JavaScript
promises to me in detail so you'll
notice that if you pause and read
through this example the result is a
quite long and detailed explanation of
promises that is more Technical and
detailed than than the explanations that
we've gotten so far because we've been
really specific about our skill level
and the skill level of the Persona that
we want to have explain the concept to
us this prompting strategy can be really
helpful for learning especially if
you're a person like me who needs a
variety of different explanations to
really grasp a new subject finally you
can ask for explanations using very
specific examples so say I want to learn
more about JavaScript classes but I
don't want to look at another Fubar or
car example because they're so common so
I can prompt the AI explain JavaScript
classes to me using an example class
called pet then I can get an explanation
that gives me a pet example or if I want
to have even more fun I can say explain
using mythical creatures like dragons
and unicorns and chat GPT explains
classes to me using this mythical
creature class where we create dragons
and unicorns named Smog and Twilight
just a way to keep it fun especially if
you're not a big fan of arbitrary Fubar
examples so that's it for this scrim
we've talked about how to learn with AI
by exploring broad topics and drilling
down asking for summaries and to explain
info in a variety of ways now join me in
the next Grim to discover more ways to
learn with chat gbt including how to
find learning resources create study
guides and test your
knowledge welcome back we've talked
about strategies for getting info from
chat GPT in a more personalized and
tailored way now let's talk about a few
more ways that you can use chat GPT for
learning this includes finding Learning
Resource creating a study guide or a
study schedule or using the AI to test
your knowledge you can use AI to find
articles blogs YouTube videos and whole
platforms like scrimba for example just
about anything you're interested in
learning so for example I could prompt
something like list five great articles
I can read to understand dynamic
programming this can be any number of
Articles and any topic another thing you
could do is prompt for articles that are
targeted towards beginner or
intermediate or Advanced Learners on a
certain topic so asking for articles
will yield not only the links but short
summaries of the Articles which can come
in very handy and it's not necessarily
something that you could get from
Googling or I could ask for YouTube
videos or Forum posts or book
recommendations and again get a list
with some links I could also ask for a
mix of videos Forum posts blogs
basically whatever I want you could
argue that this is a lot like Googling
but I think first of all it's nice to
have all this information in one place
and I think it's a little easier to
tailor your list of learning mat
materials to your specific needs and
skill level without having to do a ton
of searching AI can also help you
structure your learning for example I
can use it to create a study guide or a
schedule so here I'm prompting write me
a study guide on typescript including
outside resources for further study
assume I already have a strong grasp of
JavaScript so I'm requesting a topic I'm
providing more information about the
kinds of information that I want and I'm
specifying a certain skill level or a
certain level of knowledge and it gives
me this beautifully formatted study
guide for typescript that is broken down
by topic and subtopic we also have some
Advanced topics learning typescript with
framework some books additional tips and
so on pretty useful I can then follow up
this prompt with something like based on
the study guide please create a study
schedule for me assume I want to spend
about 10 hours a week studying the topic
for each study session include the
topics I should study along with
additional resources and practice
exercises and this gives me a really
really nice study plan broken down by
week and by session and also links to
resources where I can read about these
suggested topics so this could come in
really handy if you need to learn a new
subject and you're not sure where to
begin this probably isn't going to
replace a curated course or even a
really good YouTube video but it is a
place to start if you just need a little
bit of structure to your study now I
have a warning as you are seeking
resources from chat GPT or really any
other language model keep in mind that
that asking for resources there's
definitely a danger of the AI
hallucinating giving incorrect info
outdated sources especially in the case
of chat GPT because as we have discussed
at the time of this recording it only
has access to information from November
2021 and nothing after that there's also
a danger again of hallucinating and
completely making up non-existent
sources so just keep in mind that this
strategy is a good place to start but
right now ai model are often too wrong
too unpredictable and too outdated to be
anything but a supplementary learning
tool so always take the time to fact
check and seek out multiple sources now
let's go to our final way to learn and
that is testing yourself so this is as
simple as prompting something like I've
been studying typescript generics quiz
me on my knowledge all we need is a
specific topic and a request for a quiz
chat gbt does exactly that I could also
say something like give me five small
coding problems to practice practice and
test my knowledge of some topics such as
higher order functions in JavaScript and
it generates some map filter and reduce
problems that we could use for practice
so in the last couple of scrims we've
talked about the various ways that you
can use AI to study web development
including strategies to get more
specific and tailored responses ways to
create learning schedules finding
resources using AI to help you structure
your learning and testing your knowledge
I hope you found this useful and see you
in the next
scrim time for a bit of review and
practice we've just talked about how you
can use chat GPT to study web
development and here's some of the stuff
we covered you can start with a broad
topic and narrow it down you can request
explanations based on a specific
audience skill level or experience level
you can request specific examples to
help you better understand Concepts you
can request learning resources like
YouTube videos and articles and finally
you can generate study plans and
practice questions here's a quick
opportunity for practice I won't be
going over the solution for this because
it's going to be very particular to you
but what I'd like you to do is first ask
chat TBT to quiz you on your react
knowledge based on your skill level keep
going with your quiz until chat GPT asks
you a question that you're not sure
about or don't know then go ahead and
use the steps above to learn more about
that topic until you feel confident
giving an answer chat GPT is a really
great tool for learning so I do hope
that you tried this out and I hope you
find it very
educational a big part of front-end
development is learning and interacting
with a variety of restful apis and using
AI language models is a fun and
interactive way to explore the
possibilities as I walk you through an
example of how to explore apis and
generate API calls we're going to switch
it up a little bit and use bar which is
Google's interactive AI to go to Bard
and try it out yourself you can go ahead
and click on this image and it will take
you right to the site so your first
question might be what is the difference
between Bard and chat GPT and when might
I use one versus the other so here are
some key differences at the time of this
recording Chad gpt's training data in
other words all the information that it
has access to stops in late 2021 in
other words anything that's happened
since then chat jpt has no idea about B
on the other hand has access to
upto-date and current information it's
also said to excel at simplifying
information and being conversational
there are a ton of chat GPT versus B
articles out there so I'll let you make
your own decision about that but what we
do know is that Bard has access to
up-to-date current information so it's
great to use when you need to find out
information that's timely for example I
can ask it what's the most popular
front-end framework today and it
responds with as of June 2023 and that
is the year and month that I'm recording
this scrim the most popular front-end
framework is reactjs and then it goes on
to give us a bunch more relevant
information for this reason Bard can be
a great tool to explore API
documentation because it's changing all
the time and we want to make sure we
have the most updated information I
unfortunately learned this the hard way
by trying to ask chat GPT questions
about open AIS apis it gave me outdated
information and I ended up spending a
ton of time debugging so all that said
let's use Bard to explore the GitHub API
starting off here's an important tip
when you're using Bard you'll get the
best results if you're very direct about
telling it exactly what you'd like it to
do so I started off by prompting I want
to explore the GitHub API what are 10
end points I can access and Bard
responds I'm not able to help with that
as I'm only a language model I think
maybe what hangs it up is the fact that
I sort of asked if I can access 10 end
points so so I'll revise my prompt a
little bit and say please help me
explore the GitHub API list five
available endpoints and what information
I can get from those endpoints and as
you can see this time Bard is able to
provide me with the list of endpoints to
get information about repos issues poll
requests commits and branches and also
list what I can do with him so the
repost endpoint is useful for finding
out what projects a user is working on
issues can be useful for tracking the
progress of a project and finding out
about any bugs or problems and so on so
now that I have an idea of what I can do
let's say that I want to get some issues
from a specific repo I'll ask Bard
please write an example API call showing
how to retrieve issues from the core
react repository then I'm going to
specify that I want to use fetch because
it does tend towards using the axios
library B generates me an example API
call so let's paste it into the scrim
and see how it works so it's given me
the URL to Facebooks react repo set up
my fetch options gotten the response for
me as Json and then it says I can do
something with the issues so for now
let's just console log the issues see if
this works I'll run and open the console
and the response is a bunch of issues
from the react code base Bard goes on to
say here's an example of how the issues
object can be used to display a list of
issues so here is some sample code that
if I create a UL class called issues
list then I can Loop through each issue
create an Li element get the title of
the issue and append it to my UL so
let's do that I'll get rid of my console
log and replace it with some code to
create a list then I'll make sure to
grab this issues list that we're trying
to append list items to and in the body
I will create a UL with the class of
issues list let run and open up the mini
browser and in just a couple of seconds
we have written an API call to retrieve
a list of issues from the react codebase
and display them pretty cool I can
continue to explore the API by asking
for different information from a
different repo so I'm going to say Show
an example of how to request the star
count of a repository from the GitHub
API use free code Camp's main repository
as an example and also use fetch this
gives me an example API call for how to
get the star count of any repository
that I want but also a specific
repository to test this out so let's do
that I'll go back to index.js and I'm
going to comment out my first API call
and we'll paste the new one in here and
run go ahead and minimize this and we'll
open up the console and it looks like
free code Camp has
368,000 stars impressive so now that
I've explored the API a little bit I can
start getting more specific and more
complex about what I would like from the
GitHub API so this time I'll prompt I
would like to build a tool that
interacts with the GitHub API where I
can send a search term and get back the
name star count and URL of the top five
matching repositories with the most
stars can you give me an example API
call using JavaScript and the fetch API
C gives me an example function that
takes in as search term uses the GitHub
api's search feature to search the
repositories for my term then grabs the
first five and gets all the information
from it and console logs it so let's try
out this code I'll comment this out
paste the new code and then I'm going to
need to call my function with a search
term which I'll do down here call this
with the search term react run and open
the console back up again and we get
five repository names star counts and
URLs I do think we have a little bug
here I don't think that this is the top
five with the most stars I think this
might be the first five that the API
returned but this is a good lesson in
staying Vigilant paying attention to
what the code is doing and making sure
that you know how it works and that it's
doing what you expect that is how you
can use a language model to start
exploring an API as you can see it's not
necessarily a good replacement for
reading the documentation but it is a
fun and interactive way to get to know a
new API and start using it right away
have fun seeing what you can do with
Bard and the GitHub API and I will see
you in the next
scrim hello again in my last traditional
software engineering role I had a
wonderful co-worker who I could go to
with all of my questions about git and
GitHub and that was great for me because
Version Control can get so complex lucky
for us now everyone can have a Version
Control expert right at their fingertips
and of course that expert is chat jpt
let's look at a few examples of how chat
jpt can be a huge help with Git and
GitHub you can ask it to remind you of
everyday commands like what's the get
command to create a new Branch you can
lowkey ask it to explain Version Control
Concepts to you with prompts like my
tech lead has ask me to rebase my Branch
but I don't know what that means can you
explain chat gbt without judgment will
say certainly and explain rebasing in as
fine a detail as you require you can ask
questions about using Version Control
with specific Technologies like how do I
resolve merge conflicts using vs code
and again it'll give you step-by-step
instructions for how to do that you can
ask it to help you problem solve
specific scenarios such as I want to
open a pull request but I only want
certain commits to be a part of this
pull request what can I do you can get
as detailed and specific as you want and
chat GPT is still going to help you out
so this prompt is very very specific to
my situation I say give me a stepbystep
guide to submitting a PR for an
open-source project I've cloned the repo
locally my branch is called blah blah
blah fix broken link and I want to PR
into the main branch of a project called
super awesome project as you can see
down here it's giving us some commands
that are personalized to the information
that we gave it very very handy also
notice that we have a very detailed
step-by-step guide here that'll walk you
through it in much more detail than
maybe even a coworker would this can
make once intimidating tasks like trying
to contribute to an open- source project
that much less intimidating can also
help you write pull requests if you're
work workplace or the project that
you're working on doesn't already have a
process for how they want pull requests
to be written I find this to be a really
helpful prompt ask me questions about my
PR and use my answers to generate a PR
description it then generates six
answers what's the purpose of your poll
request what issue or feature does it
address what specific changes did you
make are there any important
considerations or instructions for
reviewers have you tested your changes
and do you have any additional comments
or information that would be helpful for
the reviewers so I answer each question
one by one and enter that as a prompt
and here is a full pull request
description in just a couple of minutes
it's a super timesaver so next time you
have a question about Version Control
git or GitHub keep chat GPT in mind see
you
later so you finished an amazing project
and now you need to figure out how
you're going to get it up on the
internet this is another area where
language models can be extremely helpful
deploying is an area where the
information tends to change quite a bit
so we're going to use Bard for this
scrim to make sure that we have the most
most updated information on how to
deploy let's say that I'm not even sure
at first where I want to deploy my
project or what I can even use so I'm
going to start with the prompt list five
Services I can use to deploy a front-end
project we get back five suggestions
here netlify versell Cloud flare Pages
GitHub pages and
surge.sh let's say I read all of these
and the ones that I'm most curious about
our versell and GitHub pages I can then
dig down a little deeper with the prompt
what are the benefits of deploying an
application on forell versus GitHub
pages so we can see quickly that forsell
has automatic deployments free SSL Sears
performance and integration things where
GitHub Pages has free hosting a simple
setup and integration with GitHub which
makes it easy to manage the website from
within GitHub it then goes on to even
create a helpful table comparing the two
so once I've made my decision let's say
I want to keep it simple and I want to
use GitHub Pages now I can drill down
even further with the prompt please give
me a step-by-step guide on how to deploy
my project with GitHub pages so we get a
full step-by-step breakdown with some
additional details about each step so I
read through this I get a little bit
familiar with deploying to GitHub pages
and now I'm asking myself well what if I
have a react project so I can ask for
more information my prompt is is there
anything special I need to do to deploy
to GitHub Pages a react project versus
an HTML CSS JS project and Bard says yes
there are some things that you need to
do like building your files configuring
GitHub in a certain way EX ET so you can
start to see how you can use a language
model to get the sort of information
that you're looking for from here I
could ask the language model to tell me
more about what a build process is or
more about how to configure or really
anything that I'm curious about I'm just
going to keep asking questions and
that's how I can sort of run my own
investigation about the specific tasks
that I'm trying to accomplish because
Bard has access to the internet and more
updated information it's also good for
asking about specific services so say I
have an old Heroku project and I know
that I had at one point deployed it
using the CLI but I can't quite remember
how it works and this is definitely a
true story something that's happened to
me before so I could say something like
list some commands I can use to interact
with the Heroku CLI to deploy a project
and it'll remind me of all the things I
can do very handy I can also ask it for
advice on comparing different deployment
services like for example should I use
netlify drop or netlify continuous
deployment it explains what those two
things are provides a table that
compares them along with some advice
about some additional things to consider
when I make my choice so let's say I
choose continuous deployment with Neto I
can then ask how do I set that up and
again it'll give me some really handy
step-by-step instructions I'd like to
point out here too that you can use this
technique not just for deployment but
for anything that you're unfamiliar with
the idea is to start Broad and drill
down into specific subjects as your
needs require happy deploying I'll see
you in the next
grim
let's talk about an important skill when
using AI to assist with your coding and
that is knowing when to stop AI tools
like chat TBT can be a huge help but
there comes a certain point where they
can start getting in the way and
becoming really frustrating let's go
over a few examples number one when you
aren't getting the results you want
after several iterations if you f- tuned
to prompt several times and simply
aren't getting the results you're aiming
for it might be time to take a step back
number two this is a big one when you no
longer understand the code if you're
finding that the code generat by AI is
so complex or convoluted that you're
struggling to understand it that is a
really good signal to pause related to
this is being caught in a cycle of what
I like to call copy paste and prey this
is the term I use to describe the
following scenario you've had the AI
generate code for you and the code has
some errors you've asked AI about the
errors and the AI spits out more code
and that new code may or may not have
fixed the original error but has
introduced a new error so you ask it to
fix that error and before before you
know it you're copying and pasting big
swatches of code into the AI without a
solid understanding of what the code is
doing a really good sign of this is if
the AI is saying things like apologies
for the misunderstanding or I see the
problem now over and over again but it's
not actually helping you move forward
this is why I can't stress enough it's
really important to take the time to
read and understand what any code you
generate with AI is doing it's really
easy to get trapped in this Loop another
time it might be time to step back from
AI is when the AI seem seems dumber than
usual sometimes for reasons I can't
explain an AI language model will just
seem off the answers might be off base
verbose or less coherent than usual or
just missing the mark and this could be
due to many reasons including the way
that you're phrasing your prompts or
some underlying issue with the AI when
this happens best give it a break and
lastly when the AI seems forgetful AI
models like chat tobt don't have a
memory in the same way humans do so if
you notice the AI seems to be forgetting
the cont text of your interaction or not
following the logical sequence of a
conversation it might be time to prompt
with reminders or the specific code that
you're working for or asking for
step-by-step instructions so remember
that AI is a tool not a replacement for
your own understanding and problem
solving skills take the time to read
your code and know when it's time to
take over as a human being and stop
relying on the AI for
help well done for finishing the second
of three for this prompt engineering
course we've covered a lot of ideas and
strategies for how to use AI language
models in Daily coding tasks to free up
time and improve your productivity we've
learned that you can use AI to
accomplish a huge number of tasks to
generate project ideas plan projects
write user stories and jur tickets
generate code and code Snippets generate
mock data debug get refactor suggestions
convert code from one format to another
write tests and documentation and learn
new technologies and advanced topics
faster in the the next and final section
of this course we'll talk about how to
use AI to make job searching a little
easier great work so far and I'll see
you in the next
section hello again this next section of
the course covers a variety of tips and
strategies for leveraging AI during a
job search we're going to cover ways to
generate learn and practice common DS
and algo problems use role-based
prompting to simulate a live coding
interview generate and practice
behavioral interview questions and write
and personalized job docs such as
resumés cover letters and elevator
speeches come with me to learn how to
use AI to tailor your resume talk
yourself up and interview like a
champ the live coding interview is
arguably one of the most intimidating
aspects of becoming a developer in these
interviews you have a limited amount of
time to solve an algorithmic coding
challenge while sharing your thought
process allowed in front of another
developer for the next few scrims we're
going to talk about how AI can help
beginners learn learn about solve and
optimize easy level lead code style
algorithmic coding challenges as well as
help you practice and improve Live code
interviewing skills before we start I
have a couple of small disclaimers first
of all these strategies work much better
with chat gp4 and Beyond I've noticed
that version 3.5 and below is much more
prone to Broad unhelpful or verbose
answers or misunderstanding what you
want it to do or simply giving you the
solution even if you specifically ask it
not to so if you can and you want to
follow along with me I recommend using
chat GPT 4 or newer my second disclaimer
is that these strategies are also best
for easy and maybe some medium level
lead code questions even for the newer
versions of the language models the more
complex the problem the more likely AI
is to make mistakes and get things wrong
if you're a relative beginner at leak
code style challenges then this scrim is
for you so if your desire is to get
better at data structure and algorithm
problems here are all the ways that you
can use chat GPT to learn and improve
firstly yes chat GPT can just solve a
challenge for you directly you can
definitely just dump an algorithmic
coding challenge in chat gbt and it will
solve it for you at least most of the
easy and medium challenges but it's my
opinion that learning DS and algo
problems with AI is best done
iteratively and incrementally so you can
use AI to generate code challenges
generate pseudo code or step-by-step
instructions for how to solve the code
challenges you can learn about and
analyze sample Solutions and one of the
most helpful things in my opinion you
can use it to study common patterns for
solving algo problems more about that
later let's start by asking chat gbt to
generate some algo problems for us so my
prompt is going to be give me three easy
level algorithmic coding interview
problems chat GPT suggests these three
problems the two sum problem reversing a
string and palindrome number I'm going
to choose the two sum problem as an
example because it is fairly common and
it's one of the first problems that
you'll run into when you're studying
leak code style problems now because our
goal for this course is much more about
learning how to use AI to solve algo
problems and not learning about any
specific problem I'm not going to go
into too much detail about what the
tuome problem is and how it works and
how you solve it but I do have
suggestions for how you can use AI to to
start to learn and familiarize yourself
with these types of problems first I
prompt chat GPT for a short short
explanation explain the goal and
solution of the two suum problem to a
beginner in 150 words or less if this is
a really new subject for you I would
recommend that you pause the video here
and read through this so go ahead and do
that now if you need to but here's the
gist two sum is an exercise where you
look at an array of numbers and you want
to find a pair of numbers that adds up
to a Target so in this example our
Target is nine so we would want to write
a function that looks at all of the
numbers in the array and figures out if
they add up to nine this is easy to do
by site with a small array 7 + 2 is 9
and you'll notice that part of the
problem is to find the indices of the
two numbers so the index of two is zero
and the index of seven is one so we
would want to write a function that
returns 01 the index of the two numbers
that add up to the Target to understand
this problem further I could ask the AI
to generate an explanation in a variety
of tones or ask it specifically to use
example and metaphor so I could write a
prompt like please explain the twosome
problem succinctly using a metaphor It
won't always come up with a great
metaphor this one is a little iffy but
it's basically uses the metaphor of
trying to find two items at a yard sale
that add up to exactly the amount of
money that you have if you're the type
of person who learns best from real
world examples you could also prompt
something like please explain the toome
problem using a real world scenario so
it says imagine you're at a supermarket
doing your grocery shopping you're
trying to stick to a budget and you only
want to buy two items for dinner you
have $15 and your task is to find
exactly two items that add up to $15 of
course in real life it might be okay if
you went to the grocery store and only
spent
$14.97 but sometimes putting these types
of problems that can feel a little
arbitrary into a more real world
scenario can help you with your
understanding so definitely something
that is worth giving a try so after you
have taken some time to understand a
certain leak code problem you can also
use the AI to start figuring out how to
solve it one of my favorite ways to do
that is to ask for pseudo code pseudo
code can mean step-by-step instructions
for how to solve a problem or it could
be as detailed as something that looks
like code but doesn't quite have the
syntax of an actual programming language
and I'm going to show you an example of
both so my prompt is give me pseudo code
that will help me solve the following
algorithmic coding problem that I'm
going to include as part of my prompt
the problem statement for the tuome
problem I'm going to ask that chat GPT
assume that I will use JV JavaScript to
solve it and I'm going to explicitly
state that it should not give away the
answer this can be unpredictable
sometimes it will do it anyway
especially if it is chat GPT version 3.5
or below chat GPT responds with nice
step-by-step instructions for how I can
solve this problem and if you'd like to
read through the pseudo code I have
included it in this Tu sum MD file so I
can ask for pseudo code or I could ask
the AI to generate and explain to me a
variety of different Solutions so for
example I could prompt walk me through a
Brute Force solution and an optimized
solution to the two sum problem a Brute
Force solution is a solution that works
but might take up a lot of computing
space or take a long time to finish its
process in other words it's a less
efficient way to solve coding problem
this prompt is going to result in an
explanation of the Brute Force solution
of the two sum problem as well as some
more minimalist pseudo code your results
will of course vary on this but but in
general you should get an explanation of
the approach as well as some sample code
and I should mention here that I got a
little bit lucky because I didn't
explicitly request pseudo code because I
wrote this prompt just a couple of steps
after I had told chat gbt not to give
away the answer but it probably would
have been a stronger prompt to
specifically state that I wanted a
pseudo code brute force and optimized
solution so along with the Brute Force
solution it provides an optimized
solution and some code and if you'd like
to take a closer look at that I've also
included it in the two sum MD file yet
another way to start to understand how
to solve aite code problem is to prompt
for a solution in your language of
choice with a line byline explanation of
how it works so my prompt is generate a
JavaScript solution to the tuome problem
and explain line by line in code
comments how it works and then I can
look at a solution with some comments
that will explain to me exactly what
it's doing now some of you might be
saying but treasure isn't this cheating
and that is definitely Up For Debate but
in my opinion no a lot of it is about
learning the steps to problem solving or
learning a trick to solve a specific
problem so I think that it's completely
fine to look at a solution but it can be
really helpful to first set aside some
time trying to figure out how to solve
the problem without any help at the end
of the day people who are successful at
this type of interview generally are
successful by solving similar problems
over and over and over again and it's
mostly a skill that takes a lot of
practice in the next Grim we'll go over
more strategies to generate learn and
practice elgo problems I'll see you
there to solve data structure and
algorithm problems it's really crucial
to understand the different patterns and
tricks and approaches for how to crack
them so one pertinent question to ask
might be what are five common patterns I
should be familiar with to get better at
solving algorithmic coding challenges
chat gbt comes back with a list of
commonly used patterns and says getting
better at solving algorithmic coding
challenges often involves recognizing
and applying some common patterns here
are five the one we'll concentrate on is
the sliding window pattern and as it
says here this pattern is often used
when dealing with arrays or lists where
you're asked to find a sub range that
satisfies a certain condition so a good
example of this would be if you're given
an array and you need to find the sum of
three items in that array that are right
next to each other the point here is
there are a lot of problems that you'll
find on lead code and similar sites that
can be solved using this sliding window
pattern if I wanted to get really
comfortable with solving problems using
the sliding window pattern I could use
chat GPT to generate numerous example
problems and that's going to give me
much finer control over my learning
experience that I might get on a website
dedicated to these sorts of problems so
I'm in a prompt give me one example of a
problem you can solve using the sliding
window pattern that's going to give me a
problem called maximum sum subarray of
size K and this this is a version of the
problem that I just described given an
array of positive numbers and the
positive integer K find the maximum sum
of any contiguous subarray of size K it
then goes on to explain step by step how
you could solve this problem but let's
say that I have read this and found it
jargony and a little hard to understand
it's fairly common for these types of
questions to be jargony or obtusely
worded so to try to understand it a
little better I'm going to prompt please
restate the problem statement for
beginners and avoid jarg GPT says sure
I'll break it down so you have a list of
numbers for example this array your task
is to find the highest total you can get
by adding up any three numbers that are
right next to each other in the list so
you would add 2 + 1 + 5 1 + 5 + 1 5 + 1
+ 3 until you checked all combinations
in the array and found the highest sum
so I can tell by looking at this that
the highest sum of three numbers is
probably going to be nine and as you can
see it very helpfully walks you through
this so if you add up the first three
numbers you get eight if you add up the
last three numbers you get six and the
answer that we're looking for is the
highest total so if you add up five 1
and three you get nine which is the
highest possible total so hopefully that
makes a little bit more sense than find
the maximum sum of any contiguous
subarray of size K I can also do the
opposite and start with an algo problem
then ask what pattern I can use to solve
it here I'm throwing into the AI an
explanation of a problem that's pretty
similar to the twosome problem that we
talked about in a previous is scrim and
I'm prompting what pattern can I use to
solve the following algorithmic coding
problem the key difference in this
problem statement is that we're dealing
with ass sorted array meaning all the
numbers are in ascending order but we're
still looking to add up two numbers in
the array and see if they add up to a
Target sum which in this case is six and
we'll get back some information about an
optimal pattern to solve this challenge
which is the two pointers pattern as
well as some instructions on how to go
about it if you want to learn more and
take this a little further I've included
the problem statement for this sorted
toome problem here in the scrim and
here's what you can do to take it
further you can read through the
explanation down here and if necessary
ask for an explanation of the problem
statement in a variety of tones with
less jargon or with examples or with
examples and metaphors whatever you
think is going to help you out the most
then use the AI to generate pseudo code
to help you solve the problem ask about
brute force and optimize Solutions ask
chat TBT to generate a solution and
explain to you how it works and as for
other problems that can be solved using
the two pointers pattern and this is
kind of a good skeleton for a process
that you can go through with any variety
of L code style
challenges for this challenge you're
going to use chat GPT to generate and
solve the simple classic fizzbuzz
problem what you'll do is ask chat BT to
give you the fizzbuzz problem and
remember to specify that you do not want
the solution because the second step is
to attempt to solve it yourself if
you've already solved pH buzz in the
past and you feel pretty comfortable
with it feel free to go through these
steps using the problem of your choice
if you solved the problem go ahead and
ask chat GPT for advice on how to
improve your solution and if you don't
solve ask chat GPT to help you solve it
using some of the techniques we've
learned in earlier scrims go ahead and
pause now and start working on the
fizzbuzz
challenge welcome back I hope that you
had a good experience solving the
fizzbuzz problem so I prompted chat GPT
to give me the FSB problem and here is
what it output the instructions are to
write a program that prints the numbers
from one to 100 but for multiples of
three instead of the number print Fizz
and for the multiples of five print Buzz
for numbers which are multiples of both
three and five print fizzbuzz that's the
classic fizzbuzz problem best of luck
solving it thank you chat GPT so here is
my very quick solution to the fizzbuzz
problem it's a series of condition
statements for every number between one
and 100 we're going to check the number
and if it's divisible by 15 meaning it's
divisible by both three and five we're
going to print fizzbuzz else if it's
divisible by three we're going to print
Fizz and if it's divisible by five we're
going to print buzz and if none of these
conditions are true we will simply print
the number let's call this really quick
so that we can make sure it works run
and open up the console and if you go
ahead and scroll to the bottom you'll
see that it is working as expected my
next prompt was how can I improve my
solution so that it's more succinct and
efficient to which chat GPT responded
the solution of the fizzbuzz problem is
already quite good the logic is clear
and it's easy to follow however if
you're looking to make it a tad more
succinct without sacrificing readability
you might consider the following so it
suggests a solution in which we are
keeping track of the output so if the
number number is divisible by three then
the output will be Fizz if it's
divisible by five the output will be
buzz and if it's divisible by both
they'll be concatenated together into
fizzbuzz and then we'll console.log the
output or the number if the output is an
empty string because if the output is an
empty string that means that none of
these conditions were met I'm going to
replace my old solution with the new one
and we'll uncomment and see if it works
open the console and if you this looks
like it is working as expected great
Chachi BT did have one final comment
which was that the efficiency
Improvement here is minor since the
complexity remains o of n however the
solution is somewhat more concise in
this gr you've gotten some valuable
practice using chat TPT to generate and
solve the simple classic fizzbuzz
problem really great work you are doing
excellent especially if you aspire to
work in big Tech learning about time and
space efficiency in algorithmic and data
structure focused coding problems is an
unavoidable part of interviewing so
let's talk about Big O notation if
you're not familiar with Big O it's
beyond the scope of the scrim to teach
it to you but I can suggest a few ways
you can leverage AI to start
familiarizing yourself with the concept
for example you can ask for a succinct
beginner focused explanation let's go
ahead and read through this bigo
notation is a way to express how the
time or space used by a programmer
algorithm grows relative to the size of
the input it provides a high level
understanding of which parts of your
code might become bottlenecks as your
data gets larger you can also ask for a
slightly longer explanation with some
examples go ahead and pause here if you
want to read through the
explanation or you can ask for an
explanation with specific JavaScript
examples here are a couple of
explanations pause now if you want to
read through them the shortest and
simplest explanation of bigo is that it
has to do with measuring how long it
takes your function to run or how much
space it takes up in Compu computer
memory AI like chat GPT can help you out
not only by reviewing your DS and algo
code for efficiency but by analyzing the
time and space complexity of your
Solutions take this example my prompt is
this is my solution to the two sum
problem please do a code review of the
solution analyze the time complexity and
provide suggestions for improvement and
I include a solution to the two sum
problem chat gbt outputs a nice little
review here comments on readability
correctness efficiency and code style
and make makes suggestions for a more
efficient solution as you can see here
under efficiency is where it says hm
here's where your code can be improved
because as you may have noticed my
solution to the tuome problem was a
Brute Force solution basically it uses
nested Loops to check every single
element in the array and chat gpt's
suggestion for a more efficient solution
goes through the array and uses an
object to keep track of the array items
that we've already looked at it's faster
to look something up in an object
because you can go straight to it
without having to to examine every
single item in the array so a prompt
like this is one way you can use AI as a
tool for code review just be aware that
there may be some inaccuracies from time
to time and that you'll probably want to
seek review from human eyes as well here
is another way you can learn about or
familiarize yourself with bigo using
chat GPT as we've seen I can give chat
GPT a specific solution and ask it for a
review but another thing I can do is
have it generate different solutions
that I can study so I can prompt some
like this show me three example
JavaScript solutions to the two sum
problem each with a different time
complexity include comments explaining
each solution and its time complexity
this will give me three different
solutions to the two sum problem along
with code samples so I have a Brute
Force solution a solution using a
hashmap and a solution where it first
sorts the array and uses a method called
two pointers to look through the array
in a more efficient way and just a
reminder at any time you can pause the
scrim to to look at these examples more
closely asking for different solutions
can be a really great thing to do once
you've done the work of solving the
problem yourself or of it least
attempted to and now you want to study
different solutions so that you can
become familiar with different
approaches and how to talk about them as
well as becoming familiar with their
time and space complexity and be able to
talk about it in terms of Big O notation
let's quickly go over what we've covered
in the scrim which is a variety of ways
that you can use chat GPT to review and
analyze your code you can use it to
generate code reviews to make General
improvements ask questions about
efficiency and to learn and study time
and space complexity and to start
recognizing how to describe the time and
space complexity of different solutions
using big on notation you can also use
chat GPT to generate and study multiple
solutions to the same DS an algo
problems and ask for Solutions with
different time and space complexities
because a good way to become familiar
with Solutions in Big O is to look at a
lot of Solutions and a lot of examples
none of this will take the place of
practicing these kind of problems really
the only way to master it is to practice
solving a variety of questions over and
over again but AI might help you get
there faster and contribute to a more
well-rounded understanding of how to
approach DS and algo
problems what I have for you here is a
problem statement and a solution to the
palindrome number problem let's quickly
read through the problem given an IND
write a function to determine if it is a
palindrome a palindrome is a number That
Remains the Same when its digits are
reversed in other words it reads the
same backward and forward return true if
the number is a palindrome otherwise
return false so if we look at this
solution it basically takes a number
reverses it then compares the original
number with the reverse number and if
they are the same it returns true
because that means we have a palindrome
else it returns false no palindrome so
so down here we are calling the is
palindrome function with the number 414
so if I run it will return number is a
palindrome if I enter a random sequence
of numbers and run number is not a
palindrome what I'd like you to do with
this is first you'll prompt chat GPT to
review the solution describe its time
and space complexity and suggest
improvements and then ask chat TPT to
provide an explanation an example for a
more efficient solution go ahead and
pause now and complete this
practice welcome back hopefully you have
a much improved version of this is
palindrome function if you had a look at
it I'm sure that you may have noticed
that we have some variables that don't
have great names and maybe some of the
logic could be shorter so let's see what
chat GPT came up with I'm actually going
to create a new file called code review
MD so we can have a look at chat gpt's
response my prompt that I came up with
was this is my solution to the
palindrome number problem please do a
code review analyze the time complexity
and provide suggestions for improvement
and I made sure to include my is
palindrome function with the prompt here
is chat gpt's code review go ahead and
pause now if you'd like to read through
the whole
thing but basically as I pointed out
before it says you could have some
better variable names could rewrite your
if else block to be a little shorter and
that you should probably handle negative
numbers it also had some things to say
about time complexity but said your
approach is already quite optimal for
this problem the improvements are more
about readability and handling potential
edge cases fair enough so let me go
ahead and go back to
index.js and we will replace the is
palindrome function with the improved
solution that chat gbt suggested in my
opinion this is much easier to read so
first we're going to make sure that is
palindrome returns false if the input is
a negative number then we'll set two
variables one for the original number
and one for the reverse number do some
work to reverse the digits of every
number and then finally we'll compare
the original number to the reverse
number and this equality operator will
return true if these two variables are
equal or false if they are not let's go
ahead and try this out I'm going to
click run we still have our jumble of
numbers in here and you can see that it
said number is not a palindrome now
let's try a palindrome just to make sure
we'll say 919 or run again number is a
palindrome so we have a nice little
improved function that is working as
expected Chach GPT is extremely helpful
when it comes to finding potential
problems and inefficiencies in your code
so I really encourage you to use that to
your advantage excellent
work the idea of using text based AI to
practice Live code interviewing might
seem a little strange and sure it's not
going to be the same as practicing with
a live person or come close to
simulating the nail-biting experience of
an actual Live code interview but it can
definitely help and that's what we're
going to talk about in this scrim in a
live coding interview you'll likely be
expected to ask clarifying questions
about the possible constraints and edge
cases of the challenge plan out a
solution and talk through the problem as
you're solving it so let's take a look
at how AI can help you practice these
activities via role-based prompting to
review role based prompting it's it's
generally when you engineer a prompt
that begins with act as a or Ur to
encourage the AI model to take on a
certain role here's a prompt designed to
help you brainstorm some clarifying
questions that you might ask during a
Live code interview act as if you a
developer in a live coding interview and
you've been given the problem below and
ask me clarifying questions about the
problem is if I am conducting the
interview we have this palindrome number
problem and this is basically a number
that reads the same forward or backward
here is an example of a palindrome
number because forwards it is 121 and
back backwards it is 121 chat GPT will
generate a list of possible questions
that you might ask an interviewer during
a live interview some examples are what
should the function's behavior be with
negative numbers since negative numbers
have a negative sign in front of them
they won't read the same backwards so
should I assume that all negative
numbers aren't palindromes good question
how should the function handle singled
digigit numbers how should the function
deal with zero what about large numbers
should it return a Boolean value and
should I aim for a certain level of time
or space complexity the cool thing here
is that after chat gbt has generated
these questions I can then ask it to
switch roles and answer these questions
so my prompt will be now answer the
above questions as if you are the
interviewer assume the candidate is
applying for an entrylevel position this
will hopefully give us some ideas about
questions an interviewer might ask based
on the experience level of the
interviewee so here are some answers as
if chat GPT is the interviewer that's a
great Point negative numbers are not
palindromes so you're correct that you
can return false for any negative input
then if we jump down to six here we can
see that probably because this is for an
entrylevel person it says try to come up
with the most efficient solution you can
but the most important thing is that
it's correct once it's correct you can
think about optimizing for efficiency in
this way you can create a back and forth
with the AI where you're almost like a
fly on the wall of an actual live coding
interview of course it's going to be
hard to vouch for any kind of accur y as
far as these simulated interviews go but
it is really good for brainstorming and
getting ideas of things that you might
say and things that you might be asked
here's another potential strategy based
on the above exchange write a script
that models how an interviewee might
successfully solve this problem while
reasoning loud and communicating well
with the interviewer TBT will then write
you a whole script filled with things
that an interviewee might say as part of
a successful interview so the
conversation kind of picks up where it
left off the interviewer has clarified
the answer to the interview's questions
and the interviewee says all right
thanks for the clarifications now that
we've established that we're only
dealing with non- negative numbers we
can start to plan our solution one way
to check if a number is a pol androme is
by reversing the number and then
comparing the reverse number with the
original number and then they go on to
talk about their initial approach which
you can pause if you want to read more
about this so this might not be the
greatest or most accurate portrayal of
how a person would talk to another
person but this is definitely an
effective way to get tidbits of
information or angles that maybe you
wouldn't have thought of or haven't
thought of before so think of it as a
good brainstorming tool and those are
some creative ways that you can use chat
GPT to help you get better at Live code
interviewing how much do you love
writing resumés and cover letters if
you're anything like me probably not
very much luckily what better use for an
AI language model than to generate words
you can use AI to write all sorts of job
search docs you can get help with
writing résumés cover letters elevator
pitches or one of my favorites using it
to help you talk about your
accomplishments that said it's good to
keep in mind that AI when it comes to
writing job docs especially résumés it's
a good starting place but certainly not
a destination I would not recommend
having AI fully write your resume but
but you can use it to work on improving
bits and pieces of it which I'm going to
show you today so I'm going to use a
couple of strategies here I'm going to
provide some context I'm a frontend of
developer who needs a general resume
then I'll do a role-based prompt act as
a resumé writing expert and ask me
questions about my current job interview
me as a resumé writing expert and then
use my answers to create two resumé
sections one about my work experience
and the other about my technical
expertise chat gbt will then ask me a
few questions about my work experience
like my job title and what company I
worked for how long I've been there my
main responsibilities key achievements
and what technology tools are language
that I used and I find that this format
of having AI ask you questions be really
helpful if you kind of have blank screen
syndrome and when you sit down to write
a resume you're just kind of staring at
the document not knowing what to write
in this way AI is a really good idea
machine so it then goes on to ask me
about my technical expertise and then
and I'm going to go ahead and make up
some answers so I was a front-end
developer at excellent software company
for 2 years then you'll notice that I
wasn't exactly sure how to answer this
second question can you describe your
main responsibilities so I'll say I want
you to ask me more questions to help me
describe my main responsibilities I also
asked for some help talking about my key
achievements or projects that I'm proud
of I'm simply going to answer I can't
think of any what are some examples
based on my job title so again using AI
as a brainstorming tool then I make up
some stuff quickly for the technical
questions and chat gbt says great thank
you for the information let's dig a
Little Deeper so it asks me questions
about my main responsibilities and key
achievements I go ahead and jot down
some quick answers to these questions
and from our interview session chat gbt
generates a section that I can put on my
resume I was a friend and developer at
excellent software company at these
dates and here are the things that I did
based on the information that I gave the
AI so a lot of this sounds pretty good
specialize in optimizing web pages for
maximum speed and scalability ensuring
high quality graphic standards and brand
consistency leading code review
processes is maintaining code quality
and encouraging best practices Mentor
interns guiding them through technical
processes and providing valuable
industry insights your own results will
vary and you'll definitely want to go
through and personalize this but look at
all of the resume fodder that I was able
to generate in just a couple of minutes
super useful it then gives me a list of
key achievements and Technical expertise
and like I said you're probably going to
have to work on the formatting and to
decide for yourself where you would want
to put this information on your resume
but especially if you're someone who who
struggles to talk about their
achievements these are some good
guidelines this is also great for
brainstorming if you have little to no
experience like for example if you've
just finished a boot camp and you want
advice on how to talk about things on
your resume I prompt I'm a front-end
developer who is looking for my first
job I have experienced working on a
project management application as part
of a six-week internship as well as
several completed boot camp projects act
as a resumé expert and make suggestions
for how I can craft resume we look at
the outp puts advice is as a new front
end developer looking for your first job
your resume should focus on your
relevant project skills and education
and offers some suggestions for
structuring your resume some of this
advice is arguable I don't know about
putting an objective statement on your
resume I've heard that that is getting
to be a little old-fashioned but again
that's something that you would want to
check for yourself and your own specific
needs and so these are just basically
suggestions for sections that you could
put on your resume and here's an example
of what it might look like so front and
developer intern company name dates
along with a description of the things
you did and any certifications that
you've earned another thing you can do
that comes in really handy is I have
gotten these qualifications from some
job ad on LinkedIn and I am going to
dump it into chat GPT and say I want to
apply for this job here's a description
of my current position please make
suggestions for how I can tailor this
section for the job that I want ask
clarifying questions if necessary and
then here is where you might put in a
description of your current job job but
I'm using the fake one that I use chat
GPT to generate for me so I think this
is pretty cool this prompts chat GPT to
ask me questions about my experience
related to the job qualifications that I
gave it do you have experience with web
accessibility standards or guidelines
how comfortable are you with working
independently and so on so I'll go ahead
and answer all of these questions and
chat GPT will use that to tailor my
resume this could potentially be a
really huge timesaver at this point I've
spent a long time having a conversation
with chat TBT about my skills and
experience going to take advantage of
the back and forth we've had so far and
ask it to write me an elevator pitch
while prompt I have a phone screen with
the recruiter next week based on all the
information I've given you so far write
a 30-second elevator pitch that I can
use to introduce myself pause this and
read through it if you want it writes me
a nice short speech that I can use to
introduce myself and talk about my
skills in a really succinct way I can
also take advantage of this conversation
by starting to ask chat GPT how I can
answer certain interview questions
especially one that a lot of recruiters
ask which is tell me about yourself and
it gives me some suggestions for how to
do that but stay tuned because we'll
talk a lot more in the next roomm about
how to use AI to practice interviewing
so see you
there we've previously discussed ways
that AI can help you with technical
interviewing but it can also o help you
with behavioral interviewing which can
sometimes be just as big of a challenge
to find out how chat gbt can help with
behavioral questions I decided to start
by asking it how can you help me as a
friend and developer practice behavioral
job interviews it responds behavioral
interviews typically involve questions
about your past work experience and how
you handled specific situations in the
workplace and it says it can help us do
mock interviews use the star method
which is a way to structure your
interview answer questions it can give
feedback information about industry
Trends and knowledge and can also review
your interview questions the first thing
it says it can help with is mock
interview questions so I'm going to say
let's start with some practice questions
the result is a list of questions based
on teamwork problem solving technical
skill leadership and so on these are all
broad topics so I'll start by
concentrating on one of these areas
first then I'll say I want to
specifically practice the star method
please give me a star method example for
the first question if you're not
familiar with the star method hopefully
this will help you understand it so our
response is absolutely here's an example
of how you might use the star method to
respond to the question can you tell me
about a time you had a conflict with a
team member how did you handle it so you
first explain a situation the example is
that I was working at excellent software
company we were working on a large
project with a tight deadline and a team
member let's call him Bob who is
constantly missing our daily standups
and failing to meet his coding deadlines
the task is that we felt we had to
address the issue and this is the action
that we took we had a one-on-one meeting
with Bob to discuss my observations and
then you talk about the results Bob was
initially defensive but he appreciated
my Approach and opened up about some
personal issues that were affecting his
work and after our talk Bob's
participation and output improved
considerably way to go Bob so it can be
pretty difficult to think of scenarios
to talk about during a job interview so
I find these examples to be very helpful
and in my interviewing EXP experience
some companies will actually ask you
specifically to use the star method it
is a really worthy Endeavor to get used
to how it structured and get used to
answering interview questions that way
I've seen an example I understand the
star method a little bit better now I
need help brainstorming some scenarios
that I can use to answer this question
what are some situations where a front-
end developer might have conflict with a
team member this is a way that I can
start to think about my own personal
story so hopefully the AI is going to
come back with something that will
remind me of something that happened to
me at work so that I will have a good
answer for the question how do I deal
with conflict with a team member comes
up with several good possibilities
differing opinions on design code
quality misalignment on priorities
project Direction disagreements
communication issues and workload
imbalance hopefully a list like this
will help you think of situations that
happened in your own work experiences
that you can talk about during a
behavioral interview I can also ask for
behavioral interview questions related
to a specific area that I want to work
on say I'm looking for a job as a lead
developer or an engineering manager and
I want to practice talking about my
leadership experience I can prompt
please ask me five behavioral interview
questions related to my leadership
experience and AI has a lot of good
ideas for that taking initiative
resolving conflict making decisions
mentoring or leading a project it then
reminds you that a really good way to
practice answering these questions is by
using the method I can ask for example
answers based on my experience level I'm
asked the question what are your
strengths and weaknesses not only can
this be a really difficult question to
answer because you're never quite sure
what they're looking for when they ask
this question but your answer might be
different if you're an entrylevel
developer versus a principal level
engineer so the prompt is I'm
interviewing for an entry-level web
developer position how can I answer the
question what are your strengths and
weaknesses the AI comes back with as an
entry-level candidate you want to
highlight your strengths and weakness
NES in a way that communicates your
potential for growth your ability to
learn and your dedication to the
profession so your strengths might be
more focused on your education
internship or personal traits that will
help you succeed in the role and here's
an example of how you might answer and
you can pause if you'd like to read
through it the some of the same ideas
for answering the weakness portion of
the question and posits that the key is
to show that you are aware of areas
Improvement and that you are actively
working on them so it uses the example
of working on my familiarity with
certain web develop ment tools and
Frameworks there's still a lot for me to
learn but here's all the things that I'm
doing to make sure that I'm learning and
getting hands-on experience this is some
pretty decent advice but of course
you'll want to tailor it to your
specific situation as we're just using
the AI to generate ideas and jumping off
points here's a prompt that will
encourage chat GPT to act as your
interview coach I am interviewing for a
junior front and developer position and
I want to practice answering questions
about my technical knowledge acting as
my interview coach ask me questions and
provide me with feedback on my answers
with this kind of prompt you can get an
endless number of questions essentially
about your technical skills and get a
lot of practice answering a variety of
different questions so this is a really
powerful tool the back and forth goes
something like this it starts with a
double and triple equals equality
question which I would say is pretty
appropriate for a junior level developer
so I went ahead and made up an answer to
the question talking about type checking
and type coercion chat gbt says my
explanation is great thanks chat GPT and
then goes on to ask me another question
the question that it asks is can you
explain how CSS flexbox works and give
an example of a scenario where you
choose to use it in my opinion this is a
super cool thing about AI if I were
reading this off a list that I found on
Google and I didn't know the answer I
would simply have to move on to the next
question or do some research and
formulate an answer without a lot of
feedback so let's pretend that I don't
know quite how to answer this question
so my follow-up prompt will be I'm
actually not sure how to succinctly
explain how flexbox Works can you give
me an example of a solid brief answer
and that will help me answer it a little
better or collect my thoughts so I can
answer it a little better next time then
moves on to a third question how would
you approach making a website more
accessible what are some key
considerations to keep in mind this time
I'm going to answer this question
incorrectly my answer is to make a
website accessible you want to make sure
that you have a really good URL that
closely matches the matter of your
website otherwise your customers might
have trouble finding it chat GPT
responds that's a great Point regarding
search engine optimization but when we
talk about accessibility and web
development we're generally referring to
making web content usable for people of
all abilities and disabilities and then
it gives us some pointers for how to
enhance a website's accessibility what I
think is really cool about using AI to
practice interview questions is that you
could easily go on Google and find a
list of these questions somewhere and
maybe even read the answers but what you
can't get is Real Time feedback or help
with how you might go about answering
the question and you might be able to
find the answer to the question but it's
not going to feel as interactive so I
find this a lot more fun and engaging
way to practice these kind of interview
questions I hope you found these ideas
useful I personally find behavioral
interviewing to be really tough and I
appreciate having a brainstorming buddy
like chat GPT so happy interviewing and
I'll see you
later
congratulations you finished the course
and are now a capable prompt engineer
and superpowered developer who can
harness the power of AI to accomplish a
huge variety of tasks let's go ahead and
recap a little bit of what you've
learned we covered the basics of prompt
engineering specificity context
technical language controlling the
length and formatting of responses
breaking down tasks and prompts
iteratively optimizing prompts
rule-based prompting and prompting by
example we also covered AI assisted
coding that's using natural language
models to generate code with pseudo code
and pseudo language also generating test
cases and edge cases debugging
converting and documenting code and
avoiding pitfalls like hallucinating and
copypaste loops and finally we looked at
how you can use AI to help in your job
search including learning generating and
practicing DS and algo coding challenges
tailoring resumés and cover letters and
practicing interviewing you've done an
incredible job now go forth and prompt
engineer something amazing